Hello,
hello all.
My, my, boo!
Thank you so much for the time gifted.
Wait, I missed another one.
Andregos, thank you for the 20 gifted.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello?
Hello, hello.
Congrats on the 10 to 2 EXE Discord and Fan Club launch!
Saw you saying howdy and not to post your stickers.
Yeah!
We launched Fan Club Patreon.
I was gonna post about it later.
Because I got caught up in stuff, but...
I became a Patreon member.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
If you become a Patreon member, thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
Love the MGS Con trailer too.
I want to call it a trailer.
Since it's not for like...
Not for...
This year.
It was for last year.
But...
You have some very diverse Patreon options.
Oh, thank you for having...
Oh, yes.
Of course.
I was like, what are you...
I mean...
Valentine, thank you so much for the tour.
Thank you.
Hello, Minto and Ibo's like you.
Glasses, Minky Ark, this is exactly what I wanted.
I wanted to match the thumbnail a little bit.
What do you guys think, though?
I don't know if I...
I never know if glasses suit me.
But, I mean...
I know many people are a glasses enjoyer, so...
I don't know if this suits me, though.
I don't know So excited to finally be a member of the
Patreon Thank You Camp Patrol Also saw your tweets for the
Fumintos Excited to get the three I ordered They're
ginormous though The Fumo style Minto Is like It's like I'm
not even kidding When I say it's the size of like A toddler
or a baby Three of them?
Three of them?
Wowie.
Thank you!
Was that the real Major Zero?
That was the real Major Zero, yes.
I know, it's kind of insane.
It's incredibly insane for me.
You are very cute in glasses.
There, now you know.
Three in a trench coat.
Oh my gosh, you could put all three of them.
You could stack them on top of each other and they would be
like a small child and then you could go to...
You could be like...
Wait, no.
Okay.
Wait.
How do you get a free plane ticket?
Babies fly free.
So you bring her on the plane.
Wait.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on.
Thank you.
No, keep going.
I'm trying.
Nevermore.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Not the size of the Fumo that matters, Minto.
I'm not saying.
Also, Mr. Noodle Bombs, thank you so much for the pink.
game because I knew you'd come around and play it and wanted
to experience this for the first time with Mickey.
What?
I've also known nothing about this game.
I know nothing.
Um, uh, I heard some things about like, people don't like,
uh, a certain girl.
I don't even remember her name though.
Uh, but don't tell me.
Don't tell me.
Um, don't tell me.
I closed Anyways, try not to spoil anything.
I'm gonna chill here about the Dentsitude Discord
experiences.
Opening day rush.
So many members already, you could say it's...
Dents.
I think Steiner hates me.
Why would he make that the only sticker in the Discord?
I mean, Tokyo class is also my PFP finally updated from the
art stream.
Oh, I see.
Why?
Sad.
It did.
Check it out.
Thank you.
Mega naming to cute.
No spoilers.
Yeah, no spoilers.
Secretly got the highest Patreon tier for the wife.
Congrats on the fan club.
We love all three of you.
I just thank you so much.
Thank you.
Oh yeah, I don't know anything.
So, remember to use the sensor option.
do i need that
yes yes yes yes yes the game will prompt you before you stop
is this game that freaky wait okay i'm okay from what i
understand of this game i'll let you guys i'm gonna say this
and you guys tell me if i'm accurate or not i heard it's not
quite a visual novel but from my understanding it plays
school days am i right am i right wait but i kind of want
wait what do you mean it needs what if i do the wait will it
be censored for me too then why can't i censor it too
hello mintolus it's been forever since i caught a stream
can't wait to get the big mint plush and take it with me
when i go places in the summer i don't know i'm middle
moonbug thank you so much i think it's really big though i
think it's really big fast enough it moves around let's move
in what no it it oh sensor trust me okay I turned the
subtitles on too I actually oh oh there is a visual I only
saw the profanity censorship.
Ah.
Okay.
Trust in the sensor.
You have remote analytics allowed?
What is that?
I don't even know what that is.
Congrats on your fan club opening.
Dense mint.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you for the keychain, by the way.
I've been going, I just got like a package recently of a
bunch of like fan letters and everything from Hallmat.
And I got one from Vexpo not too long ago too.
So I've been like slowly yinning through them.
So thank you.
Censoring is cowardly.
Let your freak flag fly.
But YouTube does not like that.
It's really big, I promise.
It's big, it's big.
It's big.
And no, two plush in a trench coat is not the same size as
me.
You can always pause and toggle off screen.
About a ticket for off, Kai, yesterday.
Can't wait to meet so many cool eyeballs.
Can't wait to support you through your Patreon.
So can they kill?
Yeah, Kai's.
Big things happening for Off-Kai.
There will be much Mito about for Off-Kai, maybe.
You guys are gonna get sick of me.
You guys are gonna be so sick.
You're gonna be like, oh my gosh, I'm going to get the gun.
Oh, I can't get this ghost to stop haunting me, man.
Paggy Mito, Paggy!
As someone who really likes this game, I gotta agree.
But won't stop you from replaying on your own in the future.
So true.
YouTube will likely have a problem with the visual
uncensored parts.
That's okay.
So proud of you joining MGSCon.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you again for the profile pic drawing.
Instead of using it as a profile pic, is it okay if I use it
as my banner for YouTube and Twitter?
Of course!
It's for you to use!
Thank you, by size!
okay all right shall we play them shall we play i'm excited
oh wow look at that it already gave me everything that i
already did i already did all this stuff that's so funny
that's okay wait maybe the animation off because that'll
make it so it just like appears yeah we just we'll do it off
we'll just have it show up normal going on her sorrow arc
just haunting everyone you know lots of okay i'm so busy i
have to haunt a lot so that i can uh suck your life force
and so that i can keep staying busy you know what i mean so
if i stay busy and then i'm around you guys and i suck your
life force and then i and then i continue being busy it
helps me it helps me continue doing more stuff you know what
i mean jesse thank you so much beautiful thank you thank you
yeah i have to borrow you i have to i have to take your life
force a little bit you know that's why i can appear as like
a full being and not as like a little ball or like a you
know like a ball of light that gets told that i'm dust on
the ghost tv shows or like an orb no that's just dust it
could be me if i had no Energy.
That's why I need you guys around so that I can always, you
know, if you guys aren't here, then I'll, I will be reduced
to, to just a tiny little ball.
Did you see it?
Sad, so sad.
No.
Why the sorrow?
Rory, thank you so much for the thank you, the thank you.
Then we can't see Minto, exactly.
you stick around for my for the sake of me well I'm not
alive but I'm alive in your hearts I mean to sorry river but
with Aibu life force yeah yeah ball of light like a whish
for the hashtag bootaku review can we share non-animate
stuff yes that's no yes please oh I should probably talk
about that right if you saw my schedule I'm sticking You're
stuck.
Jokes on you.
I'm literally made of that stuff that flies fly into.
What is it?
Sticky paper?
Can we give gifts or are you going to go to Japan again?
What are you talking about?
Give gifts to wet?
Give gifts.
What are you talking about?
Oh my goodness.
So many super chats.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you.
yeah fly paper sticky paper he's a I'm right it's still
sticky congrats on your a1 collab thank you yes please drive
responsibly you could do a little bit of Dorifto as a treat
also Tohobu happy birthday so you're a ghost version of a
vampire all ghosts do this all ghosts do this okay so my
schedule I have I have a I butaku room review I want to see
it you are your otaku collections and my favorite thing
about it is you know otaku does not inherently mean anime
you know or or manga or a game or anything it can totally be
it could be anything that is your special interest that you
might have a collection of so um as long as i'm able to show
it on youtube.com then yeah r3 welcome back so what you're
saying is infinite hugs yes
been enjoying your streets for a while cheers oh my god it's
20 months a while thank you peak thank you thank you so if
you would like to share use the hashtag I will check blue
sky and I will check Twitter so you can post to either place
if you do not have the Twitter and you can post to the blue
I don't know what anything else that exists I think only
those two right now so yeah heroes He's Cabbage Garden says,
I like Dispatch.
Okay, I get it.
Wait, that's so good.
Oh, I like that joke.
Thank you.
I didn't Dispatch name on my birthday, Gordon.
JoJo's happy birthday.
Happy birthday.
All right, play game.
I just want...
So much to talk about.
Oh, and I have the Replace Music on Visual Censorship.
There's really nudity in this.
Wow.
It is school days.
Spread your wings and fly.
God be with you.
Now cue the music.
I can't believe it.
Oh, wait, what's it?
Oh, quick time events.
Wait, what?
What's the difference?
There's nothing here for cinematic.
Wait.
Happy birthday, Minto.
It's not my birthday!
Cinematic means no QTE.
But QTE is...
I think...
Cinematic plays itself.
Wait, but how do I pick the option then?
So you don't get to...
Pick the option?
I kind of want the QTEs on, so it feels like school days.
Sorry, I'm also thinking about school days recently.
Oh, this isn't for choices.
Oh!
Wow.
Oh, what?
The QTEs aren't very good.
Oh, really?
Oh, you still get dialogue options.
Oh, that's strange.
Wait, so like, for this example, if I like don't do this
swipe, he doesn't text.
Is that what happens?
What if it's for fight?
Okay, okay.
Well, I guess we'll try cinematic.
Be part of the action includes quick time events.
I feel, well, I don't know.
He fails.
I kind of want to, I don't know how this game plays, or
rather, our character's character so far, but I kind of want
to make him like an asshole that nobody likes.
Yo.
Wait, but if it's, like, telltale, I did interactive before,
I know.
So let's do it.
I want to play the game.
We'll do quick time events, it's fine.
I love movie games though My brain is very like Mashed
potato today so So I was like It's a good thing I did a
movie game today maybe
Yeah I'm excited Let's go I love mashed potatoes Obviously I
love him He's my dad hmm what is that hmm just say what you
want to say oh it's just when you add soothing voice a
little less obvious so I'll ask again how do you really feel
about your father it's as if maybe it's a little more
complicated then you feel comfortable I didn't know him well
it's completely limited time that you didn't really know him
well oh my god wasn't around much yo you're gonna see him
even less now because he's dead oh my god just so sensitive
listen if i didn't love him we wouldn't be here right it
doesn't sound like jesse though oh we're on the ground i
thought we were leaning against a wall trying to find a man
who killed him if i didn't love him why would i be doing any
of this oh shit my nose is bleeding thought i was getting
emotionally snotty no it's probably from when i kicked you
in the face dog yeah thanks for reminding me so here's
what's gonna happen I'm gonna hang you off the side of this
building and you're gonna tell me where Shroud is or I'm
going to drop you to your death oh come on I thought we were
having a breakthrough break we did Aaron Paul Jesse Pinkman
break breaking bad break now is the location of Shroud I'm
not telling you shit you fucking loser see this is more like
how I thought this would I hope Shroud kills you just like
he killed your father I hope he fucking spanks your little
Daddy is you bitch ass to death, you hear me?
Oh, we get spanked too.
Why are we outside?
No telling where you'll live.
It smells like outside smells.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hey, hey, I have neighbors.
Use your inside voice.
Oh my god, his room is just like Ryden's.
He has no furniture.
Okay, uh, steel, steel mill.
Llewellyn, uh, Llewellyn steelworks, okay?
Fuck.
You sure about that?
Yes, please.
That's all I know.
Stop screaming.
God damn it.
Oh, I hear you.
I hear Jesse now.
Um,
he's not shutting up, so.
If you want something to scream about, I'll give you
something to scream about.
He's not shutting up.
Not the soothing goon.
Not a deal.
He will remember that.
You piece of shit!
Hey, I ruined a perfectly good mattress to make sure you
didn't die.
Okay?
You're welcome.
And now you're free!
There you go.
Oh, wait.
Wait, press...
Oh!
I'm part of the action, guys!
Oh, whoop!
I'm part of the action!
Yeah!
Oh, I thought I was gonna lower my eyebrows.
Shroud!
I'm in the game!
I'm part of the action.
Oh!
I thought we weren't a hero.
I thought we were a normal guy.
This is exciting.
I have to pay attention then.
Oh my gosh, I can't just be staring at you guys.
The animation in this is so good.
I'm gonna try not looking at chat so much though because I
think people will spoil things.
I'm so sorry.
Oh.
I thought I was texting.
Smart egg.
It's understandable, Mint.
Yeah, sorry, guys.
Oh, shit.
He's here.
Raptor goons.
Oh, shoot.
I'm part of the action.
Ha!
Oh my god, I'm doing so much!
Oh yeah, team.
Oh yeah.
Oh no, team.
Oh no.
It's a QC.
Got games on your pad.
Oh.
Time to finish this.
Wait.
Oh!
Me, me, me, me.
Eee!
Me, me, me.
What's this?
Eee!
Oh.
What's this?
Wait, it says something.
Some nodes, what?
I was just clicking.
Alright, next one.
Okay.
Oh, we're collecting the date.
Oh, wait.
Ah, now I have to fix the other...
Oh.
Okay, okay.
Oh, interesting.
I don't know how y'all.
Fuck yeah.
Just one more.
Freak yeah.
Oh.
Okay.
Sure, I know you were gonna do that to me.
Oh my gosh, I'm hacking.
Hacker man, kid.
Hacker man kid.
Got it.
I'm holding.
I'm holding again.
This is why I have my smart glasses on, everybody.
I'm holding.
Oh, I've dragged it down.
Got it.
Shroud.
That's a secret.
Hope you're having a great day, man.
You too, Maxer!
Thank you!
Oh,
he saw...
It's over, Shroud.
Hey, um, can I get a copy of that video when we're through
here?
Because it's over, Shroud.
And it would be nice to watch that back at a different
angle.
Oh, not...
It's over, Shroud!
Soothing good!
All this build-up, face-to-face with your father's killer,
and you come in here with that, shit where the fuck is
shroud you'll be hearing a bit oh hey after our conversation
I asked him about your dad fun little tidbit he was very
well hydrated turns out right after shroud shot him thank
you your dad pissed his pants but you didn't know that huh
but I thought you pooped your pants when you died I didn't
do that still had enough time to know how absolutely fuck he
He just pissed himself like a little bitch.
It was like so much pissed.
Because your dad was wearing shorts.
Hey.
Just kept...
I get it.
Yeah!
Wow!
Let's shut up.
Idiot.
He probably was so excited to hear about all of me.
And you guys shouldn't get excited either, okay?
Everybody, please.
Calm down, calm down.
Oh, he's still alive!
I didn't need to waste a perfectly good mattress to break
your fall.
Perfectly good.
I assume that cum stain's- He lost his shoe even!
Can we just skip to the part where you reveal your bullshit
superpower so we can fight for real harm?
Oh.
Ew!
Good man.
Oh!
Cool dick.
So, uh, got some kind of clever superpowers.
You can call me toxic.
Bro, that works on so many levels for you.
Yeah, no shit.
That's the point.
Oh my god, no wonder!
Your child's augments are pretty good in mornings like you
use them.
When you put them on someone who already has powers, fucking
chef's kiss.
Who am I?
Hi, you guys are right.
I wouldn't be fast enough.
I wouldn't be fast enough!
I wouldn't- I wouldn't cover anything!
Oh my god!
Does everybody who has the powers become naked?
I can't stop staring at the box!
That's like, what if it's- Oh shoot, oh shoot, I missed it.
Oh shoot, oh!
That's okay.
We make it.
We win.
We still are winning.
It's the box's fault.
Oh.
Oh my god.
It's the box's fault, everybody.
Woo!
Be strong.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Bubbler!
I can't.
I can't stop.
What if it, like, does...
Like, what if it disappears like that?
I got this?
Oh, yeah.
Smash.
Squish.
Uh-oh.
Um, that's my dream to be encased in jelly.
I'll eat my way out of it.
Oh, yep.
Bloop goon!
Maybe I'm not the pro tag.
Uh-oh.
Rattrow.
Nice.
Reboot, reboot, reboot.
Uh-oh, is this the big body?
You can't just...
have your pinar out when your boss comes in it's not
professional
oh what do you got left on them shields i said 40 but boss
man says you're down to 28 and he is not wrong about these
things what do you mean boss i said what buddy trout says he
just wants the astral pulse which we all know isn't really
yours anyway not the rocket launcher oh my gosh I see him
just one little bullet through the hole system check
calculate the damage per second hitting shields then tell me
how many seconds I need to divert astral pulse energy to
rocket boosters okay Jarvis oh hey boss man says if you're
planning on Diverting puspe- sorry, pulse power to the
boosters, it won't work.
This is a limited-time offer, dude.
What's up?
You were so fucking talking earlier?
I'm just the messenger here.
I don't want to talk to that guy.
And...
Fuck it.
Oh!
I'll go with the plan.
Now get out of there, babe.
He called me, babe.
Come on.
Woo!
Yeah, we made it.
Ah,
fuck.
Yeah!
Macamai.
I think we did a little whoopsie.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Title card.
Oh no!
Oh my gosh.
Don't.
Don't nap at the wheel.
Oh my gosh, this is a TikTok.
Don't do this.
Oh.
It was just over four months ago that images like this were
recorded across the Southland.
Videos flooded social media and our newsroom.
Recording in total silence.
The death of Mega Man.
Again.
For nearly 50 years.
Has protected Los Angeles.
Built by an ordinary civilian with no superpowers.
Oh.
We're like Iron Man!
We saw a Mecha Man Prime.
Three generations of pilots, their identities kept secret,
have given everything to protect this community, including
their lives.
After the tragic passing of Prime, the next Mecha Man, known
as Astral, generational Iron Man.
Yeah, wait, that's so awesome!
Known as the Brave Brigade.
Brave Brigade.
Leading to an unprecedented period of peace in the
Southland.
Wait, but we probably don't have a Mecha Man to...
Tragedy struck again.
A former Brave Brigade member turned villain killed the
pilot of Mecha Man in cold blood.
But yet again, as hope was lost, a third generation of Mecha
Man emerged.
We don't have a son, do we?
To become the next Mecha Man?
A bulwark against organized crime in the greater Los Angeles
area.
Until today.
Earlier today, Mecha Man broke his silence and addressed the
media.
Where is he?
There's been a lot of speculation about my health and the
state of the mecha man suit and all it all got out of with
just a cast That's pretty great and damage beyond my ability
to repair so I will be stepping back from superhero work
Effective immediately.
Does this mean you're finished?
They just he just said he couldn't Can you listen?
Ashley Reines San Pedro daily.
Do you have anything to say to your fans?
pouring the vigils it was all for you everything i've done
every sacrifice me and my family have made people oh my god
of los angeles oh big big roach big big big roach big roach
big roach i'll be right back i'll be right back oh my oh i'm
back i'm back
hi sorry Did you win?
I came back and it was not there anymore.
And I went and got it.
My foolproof plan is vacuum cleaner.
And I won.
I won.
Did you give the roach a cute name with a warm place to
sleep?
Absolutely.
That thing was...
I've never seen of that size.
Oh my God.
god okay i'm so sorry i did oh oh i gotta
get it out it's so gross oh god oh my god okay let's go back
to the oh it's in my room oh god i need some water oh my god
usually a roach i Okay, but that thing was sick.
That thing was, that thing was like a mutant.
It was beyond, beyond anything.
Oh my god.
Worse than Matara Khan.
I'm not saying a lot coming from me.
What if there's a second one?
Okay, I'm sorry.
Okay.
Oh my god, I feel like I'm going to throw up for real.
Hold on.
Oh my god.
Okay, let's get back to the game.
Oh, resume, resume.
Just don't think about it anywhere.
Next question.
Chris Stratton, Torrance Tribune.
Okay.
Does this mean you're retiring as Mecha Man?
Word on the street is, you're Dunzo.
That's what I just said.
Are you a hundred years old?
Why are you talking like that?
Answer the question, buddy boy.
I say Dunzo.
Are you retiring?
My readers need the Skinny, and I aim to deliver.
No comment.
Let's get it on the record.
I'm not looking to comment on that just yet.
That's the only Skinny I can give you.
The Skinny.
Alright, just one more, please.
I gotta get back to, uh...
Just...
Just wanna...
Preferably someone from the century...
A hundred years old!
Charles Kingsley, South Bay Signal.
So, Shroud kills your father, goes to jail 15 years, breaks
out, and immediately dupes you into a trap, where he
destroys the Mecha Man suit, and puts you in a coma for
months.
Okay.
Yeah, what's your question?
I didn't hear a question.
Two-parter.
First, why didn't Shroud kill you?
You haven't been conscious for months.
It'd be easy money taking you out.
Okay Shroud wanted the Astral Pulse and Mecha Man gone.
He got both.
I'm not sure I mattered much.
Right.
You're unimportant.
Which leads me to my next question.
Right.
Most heroes avenge your family.
You did the opposite.
You killed your legacy.
Oh my god.
How disappointed would your dad be if he were here right
now?
attack him they must be rolling over in their grave attack
him attack him right now I will not be the higher I will not
be the bigger person here yeah everyone will remember that
yeah I sure hope they will do I want to sue of course but
there's two issues there he clearly has nothing left and he
was wearing a mask so how do you feel about the crowd
seemingly encouraging oh dang they were encouraging yes I
was disappointed yeah oh wow right in front of us oh my gosh
the crime is through the roof um I was watching that hey
assholes yeah all you assholes i was watching that hey who
are you calling assholes i'll handle this idiot keep this is
literally jesse he just needs to say yo more often yeah la
moment oh who the fuck are you someone right now i'm someone
with nothing to lose yeah baby which is probably bad news
wait what about our arm we can't punch what nothing you have
you're about to lose again whatever the case i'm gonna have
to deal with a pack of fucking skittles idiots like you
skittles idiots what is that oh because they have different
color masks on thinking straight you don't want to fight
someone who knows which hand every punch is coming from oh
wait oh i should have punched with my left yeah what was i
thinking i should have let him finish talking actually
hey wait ouch wait wait oh i'm getting my i'm getting my Oh,
I'm getting my butt washed.
Oh, God.
Okay, hold on.
Wait, please.
What the?
Lady.
That guy I threw, he landed on the roof, right?
Oh, my God.
Pretty lady.
Hi, I'm Blondeblazer.
I work over at Superhero Dispatch Network.
Hey.
I, yeah.
I know who you are.
You're, like, famous.
Oh, I don't know about that.
I'm just a corporate hero for hire.
You're the real deal.
You're the famous one.
What do you mean by that?
Oh.
Right, I don't think infamous is the same as famous, but...
Oh, God.
Your arm.
Oh.
Ooh.
Oh, yeah.
That's gross.
Yeah.
It's just like dangling.
DJ let me see it I'll help you um have you done this before
usually dislocates the other way okay but have you done this
before cuz maybe okay Wow Wow okay thank you one of them is
on that roof she's so pretty you look like you could use a
drink I've already had one or two what makes you say that
one but a good one
they were all skittles colors yeah well you know what they
can taste the rainbow in jail what do you mean blonde blazer
that's her name shit sorry sorry I actually didn't know what
I meant but you know what it should have been that I'm a
little buzzed I don't really make jokes like that I think
busy's rubbing off on me who someone I work with it's yeah
taste the rainbow I want some skittles though rough day
you're good wait that's water right I can't tell which one
of us had the rough day hmm oh some water I had a great day
well that's not totally true oh you're joking sorry it's
fine don't worry about keeping up something to do with the
powers it it takes a lot for me to feel anything what is
that sentence oh hey you should give yourself more credit to
do what you did for as long as you did especially without
superpowers not true what do you call this oh I can fix that
one for you too no thanks I like this one it's double joy
thank you how wait but it's how did you afford all that it's
not water for real hundreds of Millions.
Millions.
So you'll understand when the check comes.
You're serious.
Millions.
Yeah, I basically burned through my entire inheritance,
keeping it going.
The last couple years have just been duct tape and mature.
Termination.
Who pays you?
Why did you do it?
You what?
Sacrifice everything to be a superhero to the point of
financial...
Ruined?
I was gonna say hardship, but...
It's a bar, it's always alcohol.
When I go to the bar, I get orange juice.
You must be completely broke at this point.
Um, it's the only thing I'm good at.
Honestly, it's the only thing I'm good at.
Now that's a sad sentence.
Come on, that can't be true.
Or, maybe we're not very good at it because we're out of a
job.
So, are you drunk yet or what?
Uh, yeah, yeah, I should probably be switching to water.
Good, because I was hoping, after some drinks to loosen you
up, I could learn a little more about you.
uh if all that went well present you with a proposition a
proposition a proposition yeah i'm just trying to figure out
if this is a fit or not you know then it's just a matter of
picking the right moment what's a bar i have to say blazer
that does sound intriguing that's actually oh not water god
this is like pure alcohol it's not like alcohol it is
alcohol i know because you spit it directly into my open
mouth that's water that see oh the one that has ice in it
you drink hard liquor from a pint glass actually i usually
just drink it straight from the bottle but i thought that
would be embarrassing oopsie i'm gonna go clean up i'm so
sorry no it's fine i will be right back she touched our
shoulder wait we can we can still we could still win this we
can still what are you doing hey Hey, I'm talking to you,
bitch.
Flambe?
Oh, wow.
All right, just so you know, I only turned around because
someone yelled, not because I'm a bitch or anything.
Don't you watch the news?
This is a superhero bar.
Oh, wow.
Are you a superhero?
That's so cool.
Is this your power?
You're like, tell people obvious shit, guy?
Yeah, laughing at him.
You don't remember me.
back to me hold on yeah mr.
wet ponytail you know what you are mr.
wet ponytail your superpowers and obviously your ponytail
which aside always picked disgusting has the ability to
never not be wet in battle you with these are some real like
my hero superpowers kills himself you feel good sorry I
choked in my spit no like a bitch I can throw the fire the
fire and the flame and my skin does not burn I am flamb
flamb wait oh shit I do remember you're that shitty villain
I busted up not anymore mecha dick as i literally just said
i am flambe a real superhero and you are not mecha man
anymore so you need to get the out of here i think i'll do
the alcohol we can do this the easy way sorry which way was
that hey no punch up you're literally fanning the flames
Yeah, you're right.
I thought he doesn't burn though.
What's wrong?
It don't burn You don't burn.
I thought he doesn't burn.
Yeah Some people become scared before they even know they're
hurt Like babies.
Oh Babies stop learning with me.
I have a potential girl Hey, mech a dick get the fuck out of
here.
What?
Can you just tell blazer I'm outside?
Oh my god, we were about to say that we were living.
Why are you so rude?
We weren't even putting up a fight.
I'm outside, they won't let me in.
Hey, I couldn't find you.
It's cool, I was just admiring the art in this dumpster.
We lit a guy on fire.
Tell why anyone would put those words together.
Why are you holding drinks?
Nightcap?
you're in trouble actually according to the bartender that's
exactly what you are what happened in there I walk out and
the bartender's piss the whole energy is awkward guy got
fired up like burnt hair I got a little fired up with the
guy but he ran off before anything happened so oh you got
fired up yeah does that not sound convincing enough hold
these I know a place the music It's a little out there.
Easier if we fly.
The music, though.
Guys!
Oh my god.
Wait, we're going on a romantic flight together?
Seeing the city lights together?
No, I'm just looking at her.
That's fine.
Eyes on the road, babe.
Yeah, we got it.
Yeah.
she's practicing safe flying we love that whoa oh
wow hollywood oh my gosh i actually thought you were taking
us to sit on it yeah i thought so too oh yeah that would
have been cool i could tell you about the lady that died
there yeah this this is better because you can see it and it
it looks like there's a sorry about the spit thing i know i
shouldn't even bring it up because it was mortifying for the
both of us but i am seriously sorry about we should
apologize yeah that's usually like a second date kind of
thing with me I'm joking we're already at the second date
status maybe this is this is not a date no totally yeah I
was thinking about something else but yeah thanks yeah thank
you again pulling pulling the hot you worry about it Robert
Robertson wait is that how do you how do you know my name
how do you know my name yeah oops were you not trying to
seduce me okay i'll tell you but only after you tell me how
you ended up with a name like that she literally talks like
robert robertson the third the third three times this
happened there was grandpa bobby then my dad who i called
dad but everyone else called robbie and then me robert
because i wanted to be taken seriously than one Gramps was
the first Mecca man he died in the suit before I was born
wait so this is only three generations I thought it was like
took over there was a little inheritance and the life
insurance money I'm so sorry I didn't realize just your
run-of-the-mill sad superhero origins story the family
tradition if there is one is dying in that suit which I
guess I don't have to worry about It didn't last long.
What is it?
I'm not quite drunk enough to share my origin story just
yet.
But...
Yeah?
Remind me to tell you someday.
Oh my god, I can get my feet kicking.
Oh!
She's so close.
Whoa, yeah.
Whoa.
Am I...
We can work with this.
Kiss her!
Kiss?
Kiss her.
I'm going to go.
I'm going in.
I'm going in this mine no
this I'm sorry if I give the wrong impression oh no it's my
fault I'm so sorry I totally misread that you didn't I mean
you did but I definitely why would you be so sensual taking
off my mask tonight I'm sorry it was all a little loose a
little unprofessional unprofessional it's the applies to
this I'm actually here on official business why didn't you
say that name the proposition I mentioned right before you
spit in my mouth still mortified about that it's fine oh do
you remember a superhero named track star remember she knows
our intentions that I haven't talked to in a while what
about him I work with them at SDN he recommended you
mentioned that he worked with your father oh yeah he was the
youngest member of the brave brigade so He was kind of my
babysitter for a while How's he doing?
He's doing great.
This is how you romance.
He's why I'm here.
Maybe this is why I don't romance I would like to make you
an offer in exchange for dispatching and mentoring some of
our rookie heroes.
Oh S.D.N.
Can make you mecha man.
Oh, wait, they'll fund my suit Resources that a company as
big as ours has at their disposal No more paying out of
pocket for repairs yeah my suit was totally destroyed i saw
the report studied the footage it's not totally destroyed
just mostly oh it's a big investment it'll take he's going
from indie vtuber to corporal vtuber don't join a japanese
company don't do it robbie robertson please your experience
your work ethic your perspective it's all invaluable share
it rob uh what if i say no we have a lot left to give we
don't want to be so eager what if i say no then i'll hate
you forever oh and i'll push you off this billboard hi wow
yeah okay no one would suspect a thing nope not a one wow
wait so you want me dispatching what's that even mean oh
right i was supposed to test you at the bar oh here yes the
drunk people shouldn't things that drunk people noted what
is this am i waiting or are you waiting what's going on it
was supposed to open up when i threw it to you okay there
wow this is part of the assessment and don't move too much
in there you're sitting on the edge of the billboard are we
going into vr oh my god greetings and welcome to this
training simulation we may be superheroes But we're nothing
without SDN's real hero, the Dispatcher.
The Dispatcher.
So Dispatcher, where do we start?
Okay, let's begin.
Wow, it even has like the temperature, the humidity.
That is a high humidity.
44% is very spooky, but also 45%.
Okay, I'm sorry.
And it's...
Is that not high for California?
I thought that place was dry, dry, dry.
Okay.
Begin tour.
Well, well, it appears we've got our first call from a
subscriber.
Subscriber?
Everybody, don't forget to like and subscribe.
I saw some scary, suspicious men last night leaving the old
movie theater.
You'll receive requirements to help you determine which
heroes to send.
Okay, strike the devil's fortified base of operations.
brave heroes to choose from.
This guy is just paper.
How could you possibly pick just one?
This graph will show you what a hero does well and not so
well.
Subscribe done.
Thank you.
Can I continue?
A hero with a knack for vigor and combat looks right for the
job.
All right.
Okay.
That sounds like me.
Phenomaman.
Okay.
Wow.
way to just insert yourself in to the work now well thank
you so much for the 30k thank you okay i'll click on you oh
it's forcing me now that at least one hero is being
dispatched that's on breaking forth 30k thank you wait only
one guy is needed combat intellect vigor you don't have that
much vigor i think it could be much more charisma he has no
charisma mobility a sound approach assault on criminal
hideout I will now return to SDN okay good luck Minto thank
you thank you thank you don't sweat the QTEs you're already
a QT pro he's going home oh no an ambush when a hero returns
to SDN need some much-needed R&R.
Is this how I said scrim?
That stands for rest and relaxation.
Thank you for the subscription.
My birthday!
Don't forget to review your hero's performance.
They won't be sent out again until you do.
Drupal, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Okay, I can't like click on anybody.
On SDN's state-of-the-art graph, we can see an analysis of
what skills call required oh okay let's see how well i did
after responding to that caller's well call dars welcome to
my bishop thank you subscribed everybody subscript there's
no such thing as a perfect fit use your intellect and your
roster to your advantage interesting wow there is a bit of
like the more that my skills align with the needs of the job
the more likely i am to succeed Ah.
I missed the voice that says mini-skirts.
What?
Oh, beep, beep, beep.
Organized criminals, often led by figurehead supervillains
are the scourge of Southern California.
By luck?
We work tirelessly to root them out.
Okay.
Oh, pita, pita, pita.
Investigate the dorm room.
We've got a potential villain.
hideout on the college campus okay sometimes the solution is
brains not brawn SDN's diverse array of heroes can solve any
problem investigate the potential villain hideout discovered
at the local college decode the mysterious clues to identify
the cryptic criminal so we need someone with some intellect
and maybe the charisma maybe like a brain book but pom-pom
said something but She's more mobile than...
Steiner's PLV better than Dead Sin 2.
What do you mean by that?
You can send two.
That's true.
I do things by the book.
Let's try sending two.
Whoa!
Holy cow!
What?
Flattery will get you everywhere.
Yeah.
Holy cow!
DECAL!
Knowledge is power.
There they go.
Can I like move the map?
I don't know.
They're investigating?
It probably went so amazingly well.
Ah, so it was more...
Guys, I think it was overkill maybe.
What can I say?
A lot, actually.
Peep-peep-peep-peep-peep.
Art exhibit opening.
The museum is doing an exhibit on local superheroes and need
a guest speaker.
Oh, no.
I'll unveil the new superhero exhibit to the excited
audience.
Incorporate your unique perspective as a superhero.
So probably someone with a lot of charisma.
Do we send the paper?
Oh, no, sweet docker.
We lost our guy.
I guess we have to send paper.
Oh, you can wait?
How long?
Oh, oh, okay, I'll see.
Oh, they don't take that long to rest.
Oh, okay.
Thought it was like, what's the word?
Like, um, per, uh.
Gladly.
Like, mission.
So they would be rested after until the next mission.
Oh, if these streets could talk.
Later, there'll be time.
One of your heroes needs you.
what why disrupted as their leader your heroes will look to
you make choices and follow where they lead the speech sdn
prepared is boring the crowd we're going to have to
improvise uh show off some moves or yeah uh jokes well this
is she's better she's a sweet talker i think jokes would be
better
complete these choices need the right skill each of your
hero's strengths and weaknesses.
Whoa.
What can I say?
A lot, actually.
You already said that, actually.
So maybe you can't say that much.
This is much more in-depth than I thought it actually.
Whoa.
Oh, no!
Okay.
The convoy of Diablo's goons are harrying the highway
patrol.
Intercept the convoy.
As if traffic in this city was not bad enough.
Overwhelmed them with attacks.
and going places does SDN offer paid time off to take
vacations um of course PTO accrues at a regular rate we're
working here use it however you like as long as you discuss
your schedule with your manager well in advance what the
fuck is a PTO oh doesn't even know what it means well she
doesn't have very high attack so maybe we do send them both
upward forward forward okay loud and clear Diabolical
supervillain El Diablo is attacking Los Angeles General.
Defend the helpless civilians, apprehend all of El
Diablo's...
Oh, wait, what is this?
Vigor?
What does that even mean?
Uh-oh, wait.
This guy's still wrestling.
Poor guy is not... What's this one?
What's this one?
There's a giant monster attacking downtown!
Save us, SDN!
Draw the monster's attention to you, endure the...
beast attack until it's like stamina oh so this one will be
better maybe stopping power stopping power hmm send paper my
origami man oh max of three this time yeah you're right but
then we won't have anyone for I'm gonna do these two
Okay, okay, okay.
Uh, I don't think...
Oh my god, there's even...
Grandma, cross the road!
The diabolical supervillain El Diablo is attacking Los
Angeles General.
Oh no, it's one of my arch nemesis's.
El Diablo.
That means the Diablo in Spanish.
He must have been using the convoy ambush as a distraction.
And to attack helpless hospital people!
Uh oh, my gosh.
Speaking of hospitals, You know, SDN offers a robust
benefits package for all full-time employees.
That's phenomenal.
Um, I don't think we have anybody.
So sorry.
We're busy.
Negotiate.
Oh, wait.
SDN values work-life balance.
When the bell rings, your shift will end very soon.
Okay, I intercepted.
Um.
When the bell rings, your shift will end very soon.
Wait, so what about all the emergencies then?
Your shift is almost over.
Uh-oh.
Meet those Japanese salary man simulator.
Oh, dang.
It's a good thing we sent him both then.
Monster distracted.
Um, sorry, El Diablo.
Oops.
Oh, we can get Grandma across there.
I need help getting to my doctor's appointment.
Make haste before she misses.
This is her doctor's appointment.
I think we got a...
Oh god, no.
Help us.
We're being held hostage.
Send help.
Please.
We got a sweet talk, these guys.
You can find suggestions on how to handle hostage situations
on page 234 of SDN's Guide to Dispatching.
Let's do these two.
I think we'll make it.
Intellectually stimulating.
Oh yes.
Okay, we got this.
And my shift is almost over, so we don't even need to care
anymore.
Crime stops after 5 p.m.
everybody.
Oh!
I'm like over-killing it a little bit.
Maybe we need to take more risks.
Um...
Pom Pom can help you.
Clock this.
No crime after 5 p.m.
It's a known rule.
Okay.
good good good we'll make it yeah we got this oh oh yeah we
got this oh yeah 74% road SDN solves all problems big and
small yeah we never ignore the people of the city
particularly the elderly speaking of retirement a job a job
phenomenal man does SDN offer 401k matching yes but there
are limitations your HR representative will have all the
details what do you mean it is time for lunch we couldn't
have done it without you dispatcher too true i'm going to
enhance my break time with some of the snack offerings and
our break room vending machines oh boy thank you again
dispatcher i hope to be seeing a lot more of you goodbye for
now and don't forget to be phenomenal did he just say
phenomenal phenomenal I'm afraid at this, so that's gonna be
bad for your negotiating position.
I expect a lengthy...
Oh.
Okay.
Did I drool on you?
Uh, I don't think so.
Well, you see why we thought of...
Well, why... Trekstar thought of you.
It makes sense, yeah.
Not a date, by the way.
Yeah, not a date, by the way.
Meet me at the SDN offices tomorrow.
For manum...
you yet fine send me to jail you caught me trying to steal
your heart uh is there a ladder or yeah we got the hired at
sdn achievement sorry i'm late it's our dogs damn Is it also
Rob?
Oh my god.
It's beef!
Where's that good boy?
Beef!
Were you a good boy?
Oh, beef.
No way, he's using his mech as like a phone star.
He wants to help us out.
She wants to help us out.
Aww.
Kisora!
Thank you!
Happy birthday!
Kisora!
Sorry I was like half paying attention to the thing I didn't
want to miss anything.
Happy birthday.
I was eating dry cereal from the box.
Yeah, it's just, you know...
You and 52% of players threw alcohol.
Good.
Honestly, yeah.
Beef doesn't look like it, but he's a chihuahua.
He's a really fat chihuahua, I think.
How many?
You and 54% of players kissed, please.
I see.
There's a lot of us misreading the room.
You and 46% of players let the goon drop.
Your success rate in the fight with Toxic was 88%.
You performed better than 10% of players.
You and 21% of players attacked a reporter?
Why am I a minority in this?
You and 29% of players dubbed Flamb Mr. Wet Ponytail.
You and 53% of players aced SDN's tutorial shift.
Oh, I aced it, baby.
Let's go to the next episode, shall we?
so mean i feel like everybody should just attack him and
everyone else cheered us on so i'm not done saving you yet
is a wild line i know
it said i aced it i mean i missed one but i the game doesn't
lie everybody you're just jealous dang it i'm gonna be late
for band practice unexpected things happen every day
driveway you can count on SDN to help lift the burdens life
throws at us but can you take me home or to the place that I
need to go so you can walk
what about your car she's definitely not making it to be in
practice no yeah yeah wait what's that water boy oh hmm no
just the The commercial, it was weird.
Yeah, right.
Put him on my man.
He's like a rock star.
Oh my god, he can't say the name either.
It's, uh, I'm joking, because of the rock and the roll.
Is he perpetually wet?
Cool commercial.
I'm a mama fan, you might say.
You could say.
Not a great actor.
He's not the best actor, though, which was important for
that commercial to be less.
Um, weird.
He is the best actor ever.
And when there's danger, I think if the whole world is a
play, then he's still awesome.
Oh.
Can't argue that.
Oh, God.
You got a...
Oh, he doesn't know how to do a tie.
Do you guys know how to tie a tie?
I don't know how to either.
Oh, no.
Oh, not necessary.
I'm sure I...
It's so...
Are you nervous?
Big job interview.
Not him grabbing his...
His tie.
My powers make everything wet, but moist.
Moist.
Water boy is how they call me, but yes, I am.
Oh no, it's this guy.
Oh no.
Oh, oops.
Did I do that?
Oh my god, the music is wild.
Oh, he lost his eyebrows all of a sudden.
He had them and then they were gone.
Oh, okay.
now that you your face is next to a side of my face I see
that I know you of you you're mega man water boy is so cute
you're dead I thought just on the inside you look smaller
different in person smaller never meet your heroes kid oh
wasn't sure you'd show up oh wow laser why he's so cute I'm
sorry I need him for something follow me
toilet garden all in one wow oh did you pack me lunch too
mom with my backpack take your clothes off uh what's
happening right now we don't want too many people knowing
you're mecca man a lot of our dispatchers are former heroes
but it's better if you keep your identity a secret we've had
incidents in the past here wow i remembered you being bigger
i was a little drunk listen i see that I've never felt silly
wearing this just like Jesse Until now yeah, I was trying to
imply that with the silence it worked get dressed Call him
water con Oh, sorry should I turn around or what do you why
why don't you turn around my eyes maybe if that makes it is
this is this a HR about no peeking no peeking Yeah, I'll
actually yeah, I'm just gonna there you know you you made it
awkward by saying something it doesn't look like it but I am
flexing every muscle in my body right now really okay well
you didn't have to say it like that I I want to say again
I'm sorry about last night I regret the way I conducted
myself she looking it was a mistake a complicated mistake I
can go into the details didn't feel like a mistake with you
later didn't it feel like a mistake at least not to me i'm
being bold everybody makes one of us oh it was a nice night
nothing more than that yeah i'd like to keep her boy is a
male version of it why would you say that conference room to
strip down in front of you pro fesh are you serious
whoa hello who locks a conference room Invisigau.
You two fuck or what?
We kissed.
But it was very innocent.
Like cheek innocent or tip of your dick innocent?
Oh my god.
First of all, we did not kiss.
You kissed me.
Second of all, it's none of your freaking business.
Whoa, she cussed.
Must have been a good one.
Robert, this is Invisigau.
She is part of the Phoenix program.
We take former super villains, such as herself, and
rehabilitate them to re-enter society to use their powers
for us.
Well, it looks better on me.
Invisigal, this is Robert.
He'll be your team's dispatcher.
Oh, washed up dad bot superhero with no superpowers.
Can't wait.
His identity.
All of this, that's staying between us.
Wait, why doesn't she have a, why doesn't she hide her
identity then?
Invisigal, I mean.
I guess she doesn't.
Uh.
You think I want to tell people our dispatchers a fucking
reason?
Uh, uh, let's make the best of it.
You might think these are less than ideal circumstances, but
it's something you need to get to when you're out in the
field even that's a dad bod so it's not at all in here we do
what we can we make the best of it and not a dad bud oh i'm
wet he's like the opposite of a dad bod what does that look
best by fight club fucking hot okay we have a weekly ranking
list for all the heroes She called herself Invisibitch when
she was a villain.
We're trying to re-brand her.
Yeah, I thought Invisigal felt kind of corny for her.
Invisichick.
His name was my idea.
Just get your shirt on, Dad Bod.
Dad Bod, where?
I'm sorry!
Do we understand what a Dad Bod is?
Do we?
Oh my god, look at him.
We're not the highest profile branch in the network, but
we're not the highest profile We've got what makes the real
difference.
Unrealistic body standards.
Some of them aren't even people, and they're still great.
You think it was sarcasm?
I don't know.
Documentation.
One of the three D's.
I don't think you...
Like, what would be the purpose of it?
I used to call it Triple D's, but I was informed that I had
a different connotation.
Triple D's?
What does that mean?
Oh, all sorts.
Some that are tired of doing it themselves.
What's a Triple D's?
Who have her teams?
that used to be called invisibitch quite the eclectic roster
yep we're all about diversity lana works in the mailroom
from a different galaxy all together whoa and then there's
galen way back there born with super hearing he's from
florida florida florida florida where is the uh oh need a
bio break why don't you fully tuck in your your shirt what
is this what is this look for sorry at work i tend to get a
little corny corporate dick meet me in the records room when
you're done if you get lost look for the door that says
records room it's a style everybody else has their shirts
tucked in properly what's with the massive urinal are
you getting angry oh bra i almost went in my pants okay hey
you disrobber talking about what's up even aim my auntie
named me roy but people call me roy we'll bro fist him on
the toilet yeah right good to meet you bro likewise roy will
remember that wow he's just standing with confidence that's
crazy like like steroid oh yeah no brother no no no no cause
but listen listen the two other guys here they go by the
name roy so i think it's like you know we go scrap we go
ground i bust you up and then you know you got roy you got
That's what I that's what I give Roy.
Yeah, I get it Why are we still peeing that's why they call
me Roy like I'm on steroids But they think I'm some kind of
a juice head.
They think I'm not maddy bro.
No, I'm just kidding No, no, I'm just kidding man.
Just making jokes about your name and the shitter Oh
Whatever I know care That's yeah Nokia is probably best.
Nice meeting you, Roy.
Wash your hands before you run your hands through your hair.
I guess he didn't touch anything, though.
You one funny bugger.
Mecca, man.
How'd you know that?
Okay, so I was worried about your unwashed hand, but now I'm
worried that that one here knows who I am.
Nah, brother.
It's Kapoor.
Need to know basis and Roy need to know.
I don't want to come pick up your suit or fix them for the
SDN.
Ah.
Are you going to wash before you do that?
Nah, bro.
He's so...
He's so real.
Wash your hand.
Let's put my pants in underwear only.
Even for shake, I just do like this.
But how do you get it out?
You have to touch it to get it.
Can you show me again?
I don't think I got it.
Holy shit.
Who's this freckle face?
Why is everybody so vulgar in this game?
I'm going to greet someone.
Look at this skinny latte prick.
Your bones, kid.
You hear to whip these assholes in the shape of what?
That's the idea.
Why is this happening?
What?
It's a hug, not a hand job.
Lighten up.
Be that as it may, I'm still confused.
Oh, right.
Because I'm old as shit.
How about this?
This jog your memory?
Trackstar?
Oh!
Holy shit.
Yeah, you fucking.
Why are you accepting hugs?
Why are you accepting hugs when you don't know?
Why are you accepting hugs from people?
old men you don't know 15 years has it really been the dad
yeah i reached out to this little piss aunt when his dad
passed then he got the duck in me like he owed me money i
was in a weird place oopsie i understand kid it was tough on
all of us so i can't imagine what you went through yeah so
what's up you need to tell me why you look like black
einstein oh it's true sorry i never noticed it's the powers
the powers i can move 50 times faster than the But I didn't
realize until it was too late and I was aging 50 times
faster when I use my powers Oh, no, there's like a downside
Nowadays I'm moving slower than frozen pissed and keep the
old ticket.
How old are you?
How old are you really I turned 39 a few months?
But this is what super sick a 39 year old actually looks
like though I can't complain to about losing my suit you
better not I would resurrect and re-kill your fucking father
in front of you If it meant being able to use my powers.
Oh my god Jesus Wow.
What?
Obviously, I'd let Robert have one last.
I love you before I extinguish the light from his eyes.
Was he always like this?
Yes, actually.
We joke.
We laugh.
We suppress our trauma.
So true.
All right, enough of this feeling shit.
Let's introduce you to your team of losers.
I'll take them zeros to heroes.
We got this.
Looks like I'm sitting in the chair.
Never mind.
Now, if I'm being honest, I thought and still think we
should have canned these tuners months ago.
And you might get your wish.
Because if we don't see improvements soon, the whole program
will be scrapped.
Cool.
No pressure.
Okay.
Select Unzipped Hero to begin.
Sonar here was a Harvard graduate who...
Who will not shut the fuck up about being a Harvard graduate
like all Harvard graduates.
Who also orchestrated some of the most effective Silicon
Valley...
Cyberbullying!
Also, sometimes he transforms into a fucking bat monster
that would eat your ass first after he emptied your pension
plan.
team?
This guy.
So is he six foot with the ears or without?
Or is he six foot when he becomes the giant bat?
Hmm?
Flamb.
Controls the fire and the flame and his skin does not burn.
Everyone's so tall!
Didn't you ever run in with him years back?
I did.
Yeah.
So you know he's a certifiable dickhead.
Okay.
Are we getting only all the un...
All the It's moist.
What are you guys talking about?
What does that mean?
Invisigal, who you met.
Turned herself in a few months ago and entered the program
on the condition we didn't ask questions.
That's a little suspicious now.
Suspicious, really?
Of a criminal that turns invisible and doesn't like to
answer questions.
Interesting.
Assault, larceny, robbery.
It's not that bad.
Laughing at cyberbullying is water.
wild.
Well, it's because I just didn't expect it.
It's like embezzlement, extortion, drug possession, forgery,
fraud, money laundering, perjury, but worst of all,
cyberbullying.
This guy has a Twitter account and he is fully armed and
using it.
Don't give this guy a keyboard.
Your feelings will be hurt.
Here we have Coup.
Coup.
that means two cut oh that's very clever yeah but it sounds
dumb to say so everybody calls her coop she was an assassin
for the mob then went independent okay we have one of the
beautiful babes of metal gear solid for see this this one
she has first degree murder so this guy has cyber bullying i
don't think we're on the same i don't think we're on the
same level
Coup.
I'm brachinetic weaponry.
Brachinetic.
Brachinetic flight.
Superhuman accuracy.
Punch up.
Carnival strong man who made a deal with a sorceress.
In the strength of ten men.
His muscles grew, but his body shrunk.
Oh.
He's got all the charming brains of a greasy bowling ball.
Wait, that's awesome.
Battery.
parole violation, public intoxication, second degree murder.
Malevola.
She's got a magic sword, and she creates portals that allow
her to teleport.
Her height.
Somehow she's still late for every fucking meeting.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure she does that on purpose.
Wait, her height is so funny.
What's the difference between a first degree murder and a
second degree?
He's your height.
No, he's, I'm taller than him.
Malevola.
Intent.
Oh, planned versus unplanned.
Ah, okay, okay.
Versus premeditated.
Okay, that makes so much more sense.
Because that's worse.
Actually, they're both pretty, but I mean it's murder.
But, you know, like if you plan it out, then you know,
you're thinking about it for a really long time.
And you're like, you know, I haven't changed my mind.
Yeah, I still want to murder.
um if you if you do it really like in the spur of the moment
it just shows that you that you uh you know you can't
control yourself you're just gonna murder somebody if you
feel like it yeah that's golem he is a construct oh yeah a
bunch of dirt and mud made sentient with magic
of clay and dirt enjoys poetry and basketball difficulty
with squeezing their doors vandalism it's like oh oh I will
I like him versatile all of my people so far they don't have
the best of stats and
my way out prism prism born and raised the power is weird
she weaponizes light raises some shit Whoa.
A lot of this stuff is a guess.
She's a pop star.
Why does she dress like a pop star?
Oh.
She's actually super talented.
Wow.
1.3 million followers.
Music snob.
Highly dramatic.
Consistently requests a return to her trailer.
Okay.
1.3 million followers.
Wow.
Yeah, but how many listeners, how many minutes listen do you
have on Spotify?
Mm-hmm.
You know, how many?
That's the real, that's gonna be the real, you know, tax
evasion.
So she's a V-tuber.
Wait, so, um, the Z team, my team, their Phoenix program?
That is correct.
Your own motley crew of dangerous fuck-ups.
Okay.
We're not looking for miracles, but we'd love one if we
could get it.
Can you show him his desk?
So why are you giving me the newbie?
Um, all the people that are like...
You want one?
Here.
fuck off that are you know uh uh the the trouble children
pretty sparse but feel free to decorate
r robert okay that's my login this computer's older than you
look whoa wait so we're doing this i haven't even met the
team yet we're good how many do you have Look, we'd like to
start slow.
Most people don't make it past the first dispatch.
And this is better for everybody's safety.
What do you mean, safety?
You'll be fine.
And this here is our little slice of the Southland.
Whenever there's a crisis in the area, we get a call and
guess who answers.
Me?
Exactly.
Now put your headset on and introduce yourself to these
pricks.
Okay.
Moshi moshi.
Konnichiwarch.
Hey, team.
This is your dispatcher, Robert Robertson.
I am starting my first shift.
Don't make fun.
Tell me that's not your real first day.
You can't be the sugar on your first day.
Come on.
Robert.
Can we clear the channel, please?
There's a lot of overlapping on this.
I saw him in his underwear.
Who?
Roberto, Roberto, son?
They're so mean.
I saw him in his underwear.
It was not his underwear.
I was wearing pants.
Again, please clear the channel.
I get it.
Your email.
Shut the fuck up.
Let me remind you, these calls are fucking recorded for
training fucking purposes.
Oh.
So keep the fucking line clear before we send your stupid
fucking asses back to whatever fucking cell we pulled your
stupid fucking asses out of.
Alright?
That would make me cry, I think, if someone talked to me
like that.
Oh!
Our first emergency!
Peep, peep, peep!
Our balloon is stuck in a tree.
Can you send someone?
Okay.
We gotta send someone to climb a 40-foot-tall tree, and we
don't make the child cry.
Maybe Coup.
Oh, wait, she has, like, the least charisma out of
everybody.
This guy can fly.
He should be fine.
Sonar?
Said Gollum.
I thought about it.
about it.
We'll try this one.
Yeah.
Everybody loves bats.
It's not that scary looking.
Do you ever feel like you had so much potential and you're
being wasted?
Oh, it does sound like moist critical.
I don't.
He didn't even try.
He didn't even try to do a voice.
It's just him.
You weren't a genius.
Literally, he has a certificate.
You aren't a genius if you need a piece of paper for a very
important event.
You're just jealous.
This guy rules.
someone send someone that will make sdn look good
oh very high profile ribbon cutting at band go maybe prism
she has a good talk i think a prism would be good i'm
already going okay my god uh i'll take wednesday what does
that mean tuesday steps on monday what are you guys talking
about we're taking beds on Friday today's Friday I know okay
we nailed this we nailed this yeah baby 83% today torrents
tomorrow also torrents probably like statistically speaking
okay shut up okay what's going on sonar oh that yeah um he
kind of randomly turns into a monster sometimes randomly we
are are working on controlling it.
His intellect swaps with combat and his charisma swaps with
vigor until the next call.
Whoa, this is cool.
Wait, they have, like, different...
Oh my god, I'm hyper- What do I do here?
The cray-cray bidet?
Fix the caller's malfunctioning bidet?
I'm hacking the bidet?
Okay.
Wait, what?
Why am I doing that?
Why?
Why am I doing this?
Let's see if I can do this.
Fix,
fix.
Okay.
I'm fixing.
I'm hacking.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Oh, never mind.
I meant to do that.
Uh, oh, that's right.
She has unlimited hacks on.
No, I turned that off.
I said negative.
I don't...
Become the bidet.
Best part about Charlie being the VA is people haven't made
a bunch of sonar animations using audio from his YouTube
videos.
Oh, his name is Charlie.
Which critical, right?
Hacking to the bidet.
Okay.
Some hacks just aren't timed.
Oh, okay.
That's probably because I'm still, like, in technical, like,
what's the word?
Tutorial.
Like, just a little bit of a tutorial, probably.
Oh, see, see, see?
Oh, yeah.
What's this guy even famous for?
Seemed like a loser to me.
Well, have all you want.
Someday, my subconscious will live on in a chip.
In your subconscious, you'll be dead.
At the crypto club.
Wait, what's this?
Where's the chip?
boat robbery per pursue the thieves return the boat in one
piece so probably mobility right oh coupe okay she got this
okay this is perfect my knives could use the fresh air how
thoughtful of you get these idiots out of my bar before they
destroy it and don't send the flaming ass okay don't send
wave what uh two heroes are fighting each other at crypt
cryptonauts break up the brawl diplomatically if possible
okay we're gonna send in punch up yeah all right you think
just him alone can do it and
and malevolah we got this oh yes uh so what was your rate on
this probably that was like overkill bit we're fine drinking
alone a robot guy without his robot oh my gosh we're playing
just a guy whoa they're taught they just yap don't they
disrupted by just a guy all of you shut the fuck up these
idiots are fighting over the name fight man let's give them
new names maybe that'll solve it suggest becoming a dynamic
duo what prison required oh man wait some things are locked
out if don't send in a specific person interesting uh
dynamic duo oh
give them the idle makeover oh did i did it did it work i
guess someday you're off route wait what's this oh she's
doing it okay wait flamb where are you going flamb oh he
just wait what's happening is he causing mischief he being a
little mischief maker oh that was close wasn't it that was
uh competent oh fire at a local park has gotten out of
control did you start that fire no the fire that's burning
two blocks from where you're standing you didn't start that
yeah i mean i don't know what you're talking about oh my god
uh flamb stop walking around i've got enough problems
without you I think Gollum...
Yeah, because...
But they're not quick.
Maybe not him.
I think maybe her.
But she...
I think she can handle her own.
I think quicker is better than durable.
Still on the clock.
Oh, Loan Wolf.
When sent alone in Visigal reduces travel time and call
completion time.
Okay.
Hey, someone's robbing the museum.
I don't know what you do, man.
Punch-up is Jacksepticeye.
Malevila is Alana Pierce.
I don't know who that is.
Prism is Thought Squad.
And Gollum is Young Gravy.
You just spoke...
Are you putting a curse on me?
Like, what do those words even mean?
What?
What is...
Speaking in ancient text or something?
Wow!
What up?
What's that?
They're real people.
Oh my what?
Pinto lives under a rock.
Yo, how do you think I avoided spoilers of this game?
I don't know any.
You know what I do in my free time?
my brows amy amy look at the stupid i look at the used
figures on amy amy i don't
cool paragon paragon young gravy under rock paragon alana is
a youtuber and journalist thought squad and young gravy are
music artists ah i see very cool wait so they just want
internet people It could be me next.
I could be in the next Walking Dead game.
They're speaking in internet runes, Minto.
I gotta begin my voice acting arc.
Which I have a little bit.
Museum robbery.
Security system has been taken over by robbers.
Avoid motion sensors and apprehend the thieves.
So we gotta be quick.
Which I think our quickest...
person.
Well, they're returning.
We might be able to get to it.
What's this one?
Oh, this is the museum.
Oh, what's this one?
Danny the Bone Zone Diaz here.
Today's topic is all about Danny the Bone Zone.
Shaggy?
Internet people and Jesse Breaking Bad.
Yeah!
Alana is from Australia, hence the devil from Down Under pun
for... Oh, that's fun.
Educate the Phoenix program.
Prove him wrong about the Z-Team.
We need a smooth talker.
Our prism to the rescue.
The fucker said I was pregnant.
What?
Wait, what?
Wait, what's happening here?
The fire is out of control.
How should we stop it?
Use your body!
I should have sent Flamb, huh?
Just hose it?
With water?
Why did you call him, why did he call you pregnant?
Like, why would you do that?
Blaze contained.
Hey, it's me again, Gail.
Gail.
Glazer told me to show you the ropes, so here we are.
Thank you.
Hey, a hero ranked up.
Oh, okay.
Go check that hero database.
Okay.
Now navigate to the new upgrade tab.
Every rank up earns skill points.
Let's make her faster.
We don't have anyone.
Well, we could...
Yeah, fast.
No, I know how to use it.
Faster.
Okay.
Oh, dang.
I could use you, like, right now, though.
For real.
Uh, let's...
We have to send somebody.
We gotta send anybody.
Um...
I think.
Who needs speed?
like when they say stealth is optional right yeah okay yeah
no i meant that wait he he
i'll handle this like i handle all my upside down i don't
want to know that uh oh how should we get around the sensors
hack i can hack okay it's all It's all me.
It's all me.
I got this.
Oh, eat.
Okay.
Uh, I don't know if I'm doing this right, but...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, yeah, baby.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Uh...
Oh, and down!
Yeah!
Bye, all the people!
Thank you so much for the tech gift, thank you!
I hacked!
and I cracked.
Oh, let's see how this went.
We educated.
Oh.
Okay, we're fine.
I think that went pretty well.
Proved?
Wrong.
And let's see what we have here.
I've encountered these thieves before.
I've encountered these thieves over at compile and
cross-reference Past cases of art crime ring.
Track down.
Okay, so we need someone smart.
Coup.
Swift as the knife.
Sharp as my knife.
On calls with plus two or yeah, two more than two slots.
Coup gains one combat if placed in the first slot and
mobility if in the second.
Cool.
Yeah, I will upgrade.
I will upgrade.
I see that there's this the taps here.
Um.
track down maybe like this one because then tracking is like
mobility right so dispatch your confidence robert as always
is deeply appreciated let's see we have um make him strong
maybe make him make him stronger or wait doesn't it like
what was his power when he's oh mega bad
Oh, it's only when he's normal.
Oh, wait.
What's that one?
Mobility.
Yeah, he flips stats.
So if I...
Oh, okay.
What is it?
So his intelligence becomes combat.
Is that what it is?
So he needs more intelligence.
Which will make him stronger.
when it flips.
Int Charisma.
Int Combat Charisma Vigor.
Okay, thank you, thank you.
Okay, we'll do that then.
And someone else upgraded too.
Oh, you.
Prism.
Let's make you...
Hmm...
more charismatic what if I just max everybody out in the
thing that they're the thing that they have highest yes yes
what's that oh she's a go they're working on it all right
everybody's resting we're good yeah sounds cool yeah it does
sound cool busy oh yeah I was like why are you guys busy how
to go we cracked this oh we cracked overkill for real I'm
gonna be insufferable about this okay very good everybody
hey Bobby here William Vandersnick needs a security detail
is it cool if I go I've been wanting to pitch him some stuff
I've been working on how long do I have to keep working for
oh let's see for you coupe I want to make you faster
actually wait yeah faster actually it's smarter she's pretty
smart she's already pretty fast nine to five for some
situations you can only choose one solution wait what do you
mean by that literally oh send literally anyone else Okay.
I'm a high-ranking Vanderstanker.
It would mean a lot.
Wait, I don't get it.
Let Sonar meet his hero, Willem Vanderstank.
Once you dispatch a hero, the other option will disappear.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Sure.
Go ahead.
Thanks, man.
You will not regret this.
I think I'm gonna regret it.
Uh-oh.
I didn't think I would.
Yeah, exactly.
A kid just robbed me.
Track down the pickpocket and bring him home.
Encourage him to turn his life around.
Let's see.
Track him down, huh?
We need a smooth talker.
I mean, Prism is pretty smooth talking, but she's not going
to be able to... She's not very fast.
I think Gollum would do a really good job.
He'd be like, Don't be stupid.
Malevolat!
Why not?
You know what?
I don't think I've sent...
I haven't sent her so much out.
Oh, I think.
Well, the best teacher is Fia.
Oh, wait a minute.
All right, all right, I'll snitch.
Just come here, deal, okay?
Squid.
Hideout is well guarded.
Oh, locate stolen art.
Stealth and use of surroundings will be key.
Okay, stealth.
We need them visit gal.
Sure, your call.
Oh, my God.
Wait, this is awesome.
Look at them.
They are the dream team.
Oh, wait.
just guessing oh whoever's on fight okay wait we need a
coup there and then i'm busy out there okay i see it i see
ah so she is the action okay like we got this i only travel
through alleyways and shadowy underpasses what's going on
here how long was the last dispatcher here two days how the
did that happen nice yeah nice the nerves are hitting sonar
and he's second guessing his human meat alternative pitch
relatable yeah make it relatable make it relatable you know
Yeah.
About human me.
I've got a great story.
Oh yeah.
Did it work?
Oh my god, it worked!
Cannibalism mentioned!
Insane.
Insane behavior.
It worked.
Half man, half bat, all freak.
Hey!
I don't know if I want to welcome you here yet.
Oh, our shift is almost over.
Uh-oh, wait, both are disrupted.
There's a lot of thieves in this hideout.
How should the team approach?
Get the paintings out quietly.
Take down the thieves, not the art.
We could do both.
We have a lot of combat.
What?
Oh, freak.
Half ghost.
Half made.
Oh, freak.
Wait a second.
Google, oh my gosh.
I just said that and then you posted it.
I said it and then you sent that.
How
did you know that?
How did you know?
I thought you read that.
No, I said that with my own brain.
The timing was crazy.
All right, all right.
What do they mean?
We're just locating the stolen art.
It doesn't say to get the stolen art.
Take down the thieves.
All right, take down the thieves, not the art.
I cannot make any promises.
Kill them.
Oh, nice.
With an exception, character portraits are auto-win.
Oh.
Cool.
And what's going on here?
They caught the kid, but have no idea what to do with a
12-year-old thief.
Scared the kid straight.
That should teach him a lesson.
Yeah.
We all share a brain cell.
Obviously, my favorite part of the job.
Killing it.
Oh yeah baby, oh yeah, let's see what we have here.
Another Envisagal?
So I'm guessing the more I go on in the game, I get new
people in my party.
Is that how this is?
Why would people quit this job?
This is like so easy.
Great freaks, freak alike.
Okay, I see your, yeah, no spoilers.
Okay, no spoilers.
I will I will know I suppose I think we should go be
stronger for for now for now for now and then malevola you
can be I always want to put all stats in combat that's just
what I want to do you are in charge of ZT you are in charge
of ZT
Yeah, I am Devil from Down Under Down Under Let's see Maybe
Charisma Or I know I always just want to punch my way out of
a problem It's so true
Let's try Let's make her a little smarter Okay We'll make
her a little bit more well-rounded.
She's, like, our most well-rounded one.
Have you even failed a single time?
You are great at this.
Yeah, I think I might be a natural.
What was that, you guys?
You were like, oh, you won't ace this.
Granny's donuts.
Granny's, I got this.
Oh.
Aren't you banned?
Yeah, and I gotta get unbanned.
Okay.
Wait, oh my gosh, I want a donut so bad right now.
Just say no, I'm not going for you.
have to okay what does that mean she asked if we're tapping
what's that mean access to security cams of SDN subscribers
all over our territory what that's crazy yeah is that legal
ask questions just always make sure to read the fine print
holy cow I want a donut oh granny I didn't do this right I
feel like you've said that a lot in your life what happened
this is how I found the I asked.
Well, can you just focus?
What?
You got ADHD or something?
Yes, fucker.
Is it that obvious?
Pump intellect?
It is.
Well, then answer the question.
Okay.
I don't want to sit here and fixate on it when we're
supposed to be on...
Um, um, um, um, glazed.
Oh, whoops.
Those, uh, long ones with the cream inside.
I panicked.
I panicked!
No!
No, I panicked!
I knew she was going to eat her.
was gonna say that on hot sloppy donuts love them from my
mouth to my butt how's it going first day thanks for asking
me that so you could get all your funny funny jokes out now
can we maybe address the body in the room yeah maybe check
if grandpa's okay grandma you know poke it with a stick poke
it check his pulse granny's alive thank christ i don't want
to have to lift this guy so can i go now no this is a
wellness check it's a b and e let's figure out if the
purpose still there perp b and e okay lieutenant fuck i
can't think of a character from a cop i realized what the
what the like work on that while i get another camera camera
models not camera sorry character models remind me of now it
reminds me of fire emblem like the coloring and shading and
everything cycle all the cameras in the building it's weird
getting tech advice from an old person bro i'm hearing bro
from an old person dan lieutenant dan is that is that a
thing yes i am the legless vietnam vet from forest gump you
guys kind of see it oh that's not good uh am i doing
something wrong pushing that button just says access denied
ah damn it sometimes people add extra security they don't
understand it just makes it harder for us to do our job hey
what's taking so long are you sleeping or something are you
just bad at your job i want a donut I want a chocolate
glazed donut.
Or Boston Cream donut.
Am I hacking again?
Ugh.
Wow, you're making me play the game?
I'm just here for the movie.
I'm here for the movie, man.
Come on.
No one actually wants to play a game.
Why does a donut shop even need extra security?
Because it's all front.
Breaking bad.
Hello?
Ugh.
This node has an unknown code.
Find the key.
Oh, they...
Freaking bad.
This node represents a code to use later.
Oh!
Up, down, left, left.
Nice.
Oh, there it is.
And...
I am the hacker.
I am the one who knocks.
B&E?
Who are you, Lieutenant Dan?
Hey, shut up for a sec.
You're not alone.
Uh-oh.
Wait, how'd they know that word?
He's coming your way, armed.
You need to disappear.
Why are you whispering, you idiot?
You're in my ear.
No, no!
I am the one who hacks.
We need to bake, Robert.
Eat this!
Wow!
Oh, it's pointing right at Grammy though.
Damn it, this bitch is a gusher.
Be careful.
I got this, Lieutenant Dan.
Never mind.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Wait, he's glowing?
Can you more great advice?
I've noticed, like, the people with powers glow sometimes.
Oh!
I didn't even notice that was a QTE.
I was watching the movie.
Shit.
When do I get to be part of the action?
That's it, now.
Invisible, bitch.
He knows my name!
Mizzigo!
Just hold him off while he find a way to help.
Uh, sprinkler system.
I can use the overhead sprinklers to short out his blaster.
But he still has fists.
Come on, come on, come on.
Oh, shoot.
Got him.
Wait, wait.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my bad.
Uh, left, left up.
Wait, is that?
Eh?
But this one has more.
Right?
Oh, my God.
Ah.
Eh?
Wait, this is...
Part one.
Oh, oh, my bad.
Part one was... wait.
Up, down, left, what was it?
Up, down, left, right?
Up, down, left, up, up, oh!
Look at me!
I'm too good.
And down.
Thanks for watching.
Yeah, stupid!
Punch him!
Or kick him!
Don't miss!
Punch him!
I don't think going invisible makes you...
This is where he can't hold you, right?
Granny!
I don't think you know how to use that thing, so why don't
you...
Shut the fuck up!
Oh, I'm one of the good guys!
You?
Yeah, right.
Don't fuck with me, okay?
Nobody fucks, Granny!
Oh.
Nobody fucks with Granny!
Invite the gal, stay calm.
Great fucking advice, Lieutenant Dan.
Uh, disarmed Granny, I think.
I think Granny is the more, uh...
Okay.
Disarmed Granny before the thing closes.
Yeah, I think, uh, I think Granny needs to be disarmed
because they're the war wild card.
Fuck that.
She didn't even listen to me.
Oh!
Hey, Invisigal, are you okay?
Hey, are you okay?
Come in.
I'm fine.
But this guy...
Holy the arm!
Uh-oh.
Ew.
Yeah, but it's also kind of not bad.
Yeah, great.
Okay, where's the perp?
Uh, escaped.
Jesus Christ, you gotta be fucking with me.
You're kidding me.
Invisor gal.
Oh my god.
That was pretty good for a first day.
Sometimes people, you know, get electrical burns.
She disobeyed a direct order.
Yeah, she did.
Well, that's the problem.
This isn't the army and these ain't soldiers.
They're fucking super villains.
Huh.
Oh.
Look, why don't you take a breather?
We can debrief with Blazer in a bit.
Here.
There's vending machines in the break room.
You look like you could.
a donut are you sure you're not actually 80 years old
guys i might be the best to ever do it thank you for your
hard work one what what's my rewards here take out a take a
hero out of resting oh and
i'm right
wait oh choose oh i thought it was i i was I become the
Rizzler.
Let's see.
Who do we want to give it to?
We need some...
We could...
It's free.
Gollum?
He's so cute.
Yeah.
I want to give him the world.
Completed his team shift without missing or failing a call.
That was me.
That's the thing I... That's the achievement.
and I just received the S&D-D.
Gaw.
Already mad.
What did he just do?
Why did he do that to make him...
Wait, why did he get jumpy?
Ew.
What kind of superhero flinches?
Oh, it's sonar.
I didn't say which superhero.
Chill out.
Both of my Twinkies.
The last 15 years, you'd be jumpy too.
What makes you think my life has been any different?
You think growing up surrounded by a bunch of shipbag
villains?
I didn't need to watch my back.
You need better friends.
Yeah, well, I guess you should do a better job picking your
friends.
What the fuck?
You can't just go around.
Ow!
Why is he keep screaming?
His name's Sonar.
Yeah, I know what Sonar means.
What's up?
Then why are you asking why he keeps screaming?
She was just explaining your, um...
You know what?
Never mind.
Good shift.
This guy is weird.
Yeah, he is.
Look, I actually just came by to celebrate the mission going
well.
Didn't mean to interrupt your little snack What do you need
to preach you like a little baby bird bitch you ignore my
order to disobey a direct order How can you think it went
well?
Yeah, you trashed the place the suspect got away and you got
the client hurt I don't think when he called us thought he'd
be ending the day winking at lefty because you turned his
other arm into a pork Grind granny would be fine if granny
didn't pick that fucking thing up in the first place the
storks Dumbass trying to be a hero and don't fucking say it
Storks poster We could have had an outcome where the client
doesn't get cried and we get the perp if you had just
fucking listened to me Dude, you ask for help then I can See
grinding coffee beans.
Oh my god.
He really is I make the calls not you Why does my game
sometimes flicker?
Are we gonna say no?
Or is it this one?
You're no hero.
You were a nerd playing a video game in a suit your daddy
built Now you're a twitchy little bitch turtle without a
shelf a real hero puts their ass on the line a real hero
can't just press a button make their problems disappear.
Let me make this clear.
You're not half the hero that I am.
Yeah, you tell.
Based on what I saw today, you wouldn't last a day as
Mechamander.
Because there isn't a Mech suit in the universe that will
keep you from being a selfish fucking asshole.
Oh, get her.
Yeah.
She needs an attitude check.
Oh.
Good.
Fuck you.
Oh my god.
We're back on the ground.
You're gonna eat those twinks?
That's not what they're... you know what?
Help yourself.
You're gonna eat those twinks disobeyed by Invisible gal.
Here we go.
You have a tissue hanging from your nose, Robert.
That's what that's the achievement I got.
I was trying to ignore it, but that became impossible.
The air's dry.
Soaking in blood.
Uh, I get nosebleeds when it's this dry.
And the air.
And the office.
It's, uh, it's on the dry side.
Is it on the dry side?
I have to check.
Still bad.
I'll have facilities look into it.
All right, boys.
We're here to assess Robert's first shift.
And aside from whatever happened here, I thought it was
pretty good.
Yeah, I think it was great.
I was watching on the monitor.
The work you did dispatching.
I don't think the Z team has ever had a better shift than
that.
Oh, man.
If I did poorly, would she fire me?
Yeah, no, the granny's situation.
Changing B-Sync might fix the flickering issue.
Oh, I see.
Let's be real.
She ain't gonna make it.
She's difficult to work with.
But I see a lot of friends.
We can buy her.
Oh, thank you for the Rita Ray.
Hello, Raiders.
Oh, uh.
I should have done better.
Oh, sorry.
I was looking.
Oh, my gosh.
Sorry.
I can't look away with the quick time.
With her.
zero wires okay she crossed them for you look robert you
should be proud the bar is very low with this group well
it's not low for me look thank you guys for the gift thank
you so much as much as the next person but when it comes to
work i'm not around here if you want the phoenix program to
survive the bar needs to go up and how would we do that by
treating the z team like what they are a bunch of villains
and leading a super villain team takes a different approach
than a superhero team i need to be around interesting i need
them to see i'm all in and they need to match that energy
the only kind i know and based on what i've seen the only
version they'll respond to i'm not saying everyone will make
it they won't i'm not saying i won't get spicy spicy but
when it does i also need you to trust me to handle it i
don't want you stepping in they need to respect me even if i
don't have powers Yeah.
That's so true though.
We'll do it your way.
Villains are like so like, you gotta earn the respect.
Yeah.
No fucking way is gonna work, but it'll be way more fun to
watch.
Chase, some optimism please.
God damn it.
Yeah, I also promised to do my best.
I still hate his shirt though.
Mr. Moist?
What are you doing?
Yeah.
No, no, no, no, I didn't did this.
It's weird because, yeah, I saw this lady, smiling lady.
Person put a donut on your desk earlier.
Aw.
It was nice, nicely on a napkin.
And then she just, she comes back and she just, it's crazy.
Like, evil.
Oh, she, she, she gave us a donut.
I will clean it.
What, no, no, no.
No, yes, see, I'm SDN's newest.
You're so wet.
Hey, he's a hero, helpful janitor, helpful janitor.
Oh.
Cool.
So, it's my pleases pleasure.
Pleases pleasure.
No.
You help me get.
So, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Help you to help.
That's, it's Friday.
I'm not gonna ask.
You headed out?
Oh, yeah.
He's so cute.
Thanks, kid.
Welcome to the team, Waterboy.
Yeah, well, Welcome to you.
You too.
God!
What?
I want you to know us fixing your suit is not contingent on
you fixing the Z team.
Oh, that's how we get...
But don't worry about that.
I'm just really glad you're here.
Um, do you want to grab dinner?
I'm just going to do some great things together.
I'm all in.
So do you want to grab dinner or something?
It's dinner time, so I assume that maybe...
know uh actually there's something i've been meaning to tell
you it's a little she's like i have a boyfriend since the
other night i blonde blazer is it for mama man her her
boyfriend are you ready to go who is this i thought i'd
cataloged all of your work companions yeah what this is my
boyfriend i thought it was her dad i thought she was gonna
say it was her dad i was telling you about she has an
overprotective dad robertson leader of the phoenixes blonde
blazer told me about you really did she um say i don't know
what came up in that talk she said you're a capable
honorable man that truly cares for others why are you so
small hey come on you gotta stop asking people that the way
you spoke of him made him sound impressive i only see we're
just the side piece
strength and issue no he was great it was great it was a
great first thing i think she likes me we should celebrate
blonde blazer and i have reservations in tokyo in tokyo for
the owner dreams of sushi you should join us i'm sure they
could accommodate one more especially a special occasion
like this i gotta get actually i gotta get home i would have
for the drama oh of course but oh my gosh responsible for
another life is a beautiful thing because she said no Even
if that life is a dog life.
Yeah, right.
Why is this VTuber so small?
Oh.
He flies a little faster.
It was very nice to meet you.
Third Robert Robertson.
Now, could you step back?
The power of my launch has been known to stun small beings.
Yeah, I'm not that much smaller than you!
I'ma show you how to...
Let's see how we did, everybody.
93% of players brofisted, okay.
Everybody's polite.
You and 75% of players covered for InvisiCout.
Wow.
You and 34% of players prefer long-drawn donuts.
I don't!
It was a mistake.
You and 28% of players attempted to pass your blazer out.
This is Thought Squad, Prison's VA.
Ah, okay, I see, I see.
I love fire truck music.
You and, uh, I feel like you and 89% of players said no to
dinner.
I feel like like we should have gone to dinner i feel like
we should have i feel like we should have said yes maybe we
give up on lawn blazer okay fire truck yeah because it
sounded like a fire truck you know you and 37 of players let
sonar meet van der stank and it went great yeah i did it i
did well you and 39 of players convinced the fight men to
form a crime duo the fight men oh wait was it fight and man
and so we made fight men it's awesome your most sent hero
was sonar you performed better than 80 of players in today's
ship no way i performed better than 80 how
I didn't think...
What?
Wow, top 20%, baby.
I might be a genius.
Oh, man, I should have gone on the date.
So this is episode three.
How many episodes are there?
Hey, hey, hey.
eight okay she's really god yeah i'm a crack dispatcher it's
my expertise as in a former ol everybody
it's my expertise
whoa whoa whoa whoa hey what are you doing rata you're
worthy Aww.
Be gentle with her.
How can you just toss it around like that?
No worries.
I'm pretty strong.
That's not what I'm saying.
How you got this thing inside your apartment anyways?
Super heavy, the bugger.
I disassembled it and took it in little pieces.
Whoa.
This is what I thought you'd be doing.
And how long that take you?
A long time.
No, it was four days.
I get 20 minutes.
Wait, but he always would have to disassemble it and bring
it in there?
It is, you know.
This guy in his riding apartment.
Holy hell.
He's got nothing in here.
I'm poor.
Or no one never come over to tell you that.
I'm poor, Royd.
Is that what you want to hear?
Does that make you feel good?
You're not poor if you can keep this suit going.
Like, where are you sleep?
We're figuring that out.
You're figuring that out, huh?
Oh.
Even a beef got a bed.
Beef.
This is the type of apartment you see.
When the detective kicked the door in, you know?
Shine the flashlight.
Serial killer shit.
That's so true, though.
Serial killer?
Riding.
Lost in the blast while I was flying.
No clue where I landed.
Uh-oh.
I spent a couple weeks after it happened trying to track it
down.
They powered a whole suit.
Yeah, it's the only piece of the suit my dad didn't have
schematics for.
Oh.
That can be a problem?
Yeah, maybe.
Ah, mine now.
We figure them out.
Ah.
I like growing.
We know about the Astral Pulse.
We've...
Everybody know about them.
There's actually two wicked pieces of tech, huh?
Thank you, Nick.
First you get the Anthropos, this genius design energy cell.
But inside them, you get the stellar core.
Can I help?
No, brother.
You good.
Ow.
He's got the dog.
It's when you mix the control fusion reactions with the
plasma containment.
Oh, brother.
You got a core one super crazy energy.
Carmen looks like the owner eats gunpowder.
Like you caught one small star and chop them in a bottle.
Genius.
Can you recreate it?
So you can just make me a new one, right?
Which is why it's not a puzzle.
problem right super awesome but uh we'll be all right
what if what if it's inside brief what if he ate it
you know what if he's the real super dog long time ago first
time i come mainland oh you can't be trying for steal stuff
from radio shack then we talk tech stuff for like an whole
hour then he'll take me jail oh that's how i ended up in a
phoenix program oh is everyone like was everyone a villain
first.
Bombers.
Guess when you're building Astropulses, there's not much
time for talking to your son.
Not so sure about that.
I don't understand.
You see, there's gearheads then there's science nerds.
One kind garage, the other kind lab.
I'm the metal gearhead.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm a good gearhead, but I just can't see how he'll make
something like the pulse.
He knows science nerd.
How would you know this from talking to him once?
Because I'm both.
Ah.
True.
I'm the one going to fix your suit.
Whoa!
The lab.
That one over there.
That's your father's suit.
Oh my god, he put the glasses on.
He's in super nerd mode.
This is incredible, Roy.
Wow.
I hope you like it, brother.
Roy, I don't know what to say.
Thank you.
Thank you is what I need to say.
this this is unreal we make the man mecca again
yeah we're getting the seat and the i mean the suit oh no
now watch where you're going hey watch where you're going
Callum will remember that.
Did you did that on purpose?
Wait, is we can bring our dog to work?
Kobe.
Why doesn't he respond to me though?
Oh, I...
What does it say?
Hey, Chase, I need a favor.
It's not enough of a favor getting you this job working with
those stupid ass pieces of...
Oh!
Shit, huh?
Who's the little guy?
His name's beef.
and he's the favor you mind keeping an eye out i feel bad
leaving him at home but i don't want anything happening to
him robert i would literally let everyone here melt in
eternal hell including you before anything happens to this
dog so true what's your name little guy oh yeah my name's
beef and i'm naked oh no i refuse to believe that's what he
sounds like oh why would you give him a voice like that yeah
i think i give my cat a really dumb voice too though but not
like that just kind of sounds pathetic my cat about the
other day with phenomenon man why did he choose such a
terrible oh it was awkward it's why I didn't want you to
come Phenoma man and I broke up over Tokyo dream sushi our
shot it's just oh my god the timing felt right I don't know
sometimes you just gotta shake shut up it felt a little
impulsive but maybe it was a long time coming hope I didn't
contribute I didn't contribute to anything.
Oh, why would you have contributed to?
Yes, that means I didn't.
Such a terrible thing to say.
Which is what I was hoping for.
It is what it is.
But that's actually not what I wanted to talk to you about.
Yeah?
I was thinking about it over the weekend, and I'm going to
cut someone from the Z team.
Or you are.
Wait, why?
Maybe I'm just looking to shake things up all over the
place.
Oh.
I need a sense of urgency.
You sure about that?
Wait, but my team!
I'm sure now.
Well, what if it's somebody that I gave them?
points to how it'll play out what the reality is cutting
someone towards the bottom of the leaderboards will show
everyone we're serious what I'll let the team know oh I
already did oh I suppose it'll be an interesting shift okay
my investment yeah oh cut me huh yeah she ain't bad those
three ain't shit did you come over here to tell me that
because it's Big Chuggist?
Who is Horse Girl?
I wanna meet Horse Girl.
Alright, team!
Donar, you alright?
Why are you sending a distress call when you haven't left
the building?
Could you send a locksmith downstairs?
What happened?
Coop seduced me.
I said, hey, wanna say something cool, and then...
You
meant boobs.
Okay, team, I know Blazer mentioned someone's getting cut
but don't let that distract you from doing a good job out
there that's what you'll be judged on sorry what's bullshit
how was that okay false I'm judging right now it wasn't a
promise of boobs but also false of course I'm being judged
along with the rest of you are you do you not know what a
job is what the hell is going on what if I if I lose
somebody we're for sure all right ignore the pressure and do
your job sure not have enough first you just can't be last
can somebody go down to the gym and help bat boner bat boner
don't ask all right everybody in my hand and not in a fun
kinky way he's still handcuffed wait why what is f oh that's
my um take a hero out of resting okay all right there was an
altercation Lock in, everybody.
There's body parts left behind.
Body parts.
Remove giant monster remains from the beach.
So we need someone physically fit.
Large media.
I think we got ascending Gollum.
I think Gollum's our guide.
Look different.
Oh, on a call with more than two slots.
Certain slots may grant plus two to a stat and minus one to
others when Gollum is assigned.
Oh, what does that mean?
Oh, hey.
Oh, wait, I didn't press that.
Wait.
No.
Wait, what do you mean, no?
Huh?
She just put herself in.
Wait, what?
No?
Okay.
What happened?
I didn't know dogs could be so huge!
Um...
Entice it with food!
Yes?
Yeah!
Hero saves.
good job it's strategic wait why is she returning uh-huh you
know this is uh really immature what's happening serves them
right you let your guard down you perish that's a pretty
fucked way to live emphasis on live oh my god you do realize
that sabotaging each other isn't going to guarantee you a
spot on the team oh that's never punished punished.
Holy cow.
Let's see.
Let's give you...
That was close.
That was so scary.
Let's give you...
More...
combat.
I feel like you should have a high combat.
Maybe he doesn't because he's just mud.
I guess he's a defender, right?
Versatile.
Hmm.
Riz make him giving me the poor charisma.
We could also lean into the vigor a bit more.
But I find...
Well...
Hmm.
He might be mud, but he's our bud.
Yeah!
Uh...
I feel like I have a couple other people that are high in
charisma.
We have Prism?
Oh, wait.
Maybe not.
Well, punch-up is pretty high in charisma.
Let's go with more vigor.
Because I don't think anybody else is as high as him.
Okay.
Oop.
There's a drug deal happening at the airport right now.
I think you should send the bat guy.
The bat?
Why would you say that?
Convincingly pose as a buyer.
Okay.
Preferably someone highly educated on drugs.
Oh!
He is!
Wait, I was supposed to memorize all that stuff?
Hatsu snow!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Wait, that is kind of sus, isn't it?
I think he can bring up the dossier.
Can you?
Oh, info.
Here we go.
Wait, who else, though?
There was definitely other people.
Assault, arson.
vandalism larceny public intoxication ah prism my gal uh
okay prism it's all you girl I'm not sending Batman
I'm not sending him oh okay I see you picking from the cream
of the crop Mm-hmm.
Yes.
Blit-lit-l-l-p.
So, uh, turtle fans moved in, flipped a grill, started a
fight, and ruined a bunch of hot dogs.
Hot dogs!
Break up a fight, go on the offensive if you have to.
Alright, Flambe, it might be...
I hate this guy.
Break up a fight, eh?
Ooh.
Yeah.
Close your eyes.
You're not going to like what you see anyway.
They got this.
They got this for sure.
Wait.
All of these sabotages me, except me.
Why get in the pot in the first place?
She's locked in a sensory deprivation tank.
I'll have to use it again sometime.
What?
Blast the lid off.
You got this.
It probably will work.
Yeah!
Wait, where is he going?
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Oopsie.
you actually want to be here oops i messed up guys golem
docs prism who is now being what is happening it's
intimidating and i think it's too late for crowd control
what distract them with the song this is insane
playing the hits works every time there's something sketchy
happening in the mall parking lot I think it's a drug deal.
We gotta protect and defend civilians at all costs.
We gotta shut down the deal.
Um.
All my people are busy.
Wait, hold on.
What's this one?
Hey, my grandma just got scammed by someone claiming they
work for you guys.
Oh no!
Social security numbers.
They keep selling the blue stuff.
Speak to a victim.
Victim gather intel.
Okay, so we need someone.
Charming it Gather and smart It's this guy He's gotta go But
bear toe my boy Excellent choice First of many we could make
together Oh Come on, we got sabotaged for Real Uh oh When a
hero gets injured Their stats are decreased by one if a hero
gets hurt again They become down Oh, dang.
Okay.
That's your fault for locking that guy in the pod.
We would have been fine if she hadn't locked him in the pod.
Okay.
Shut down the deal.
We'll send out Malevola.
Oh, whatever you say.
And it's a girl's...
It's the girl's dream team.
Good.
What's happened?
Betrayed by a fellow degenerate.
Malevolent paid a kid to stalk and visit gal with a spy
camera.
Break the camera.
I don't know.
I think it's a pretty good choice.
Yeah, exactly.
Great.
Now there's camera guts in my sneakers.
What do you...
Why did you leave?
What is actually going on here?
This could be fine.
Oh, guys.
it's because I did so well on the first one this is so bad
this is so bad I'm being savage Taj left and right if I make
this it's a miracle I was so close great yeah that's exactly
what I figured would fucking happen this is so bad landslide
someone that can figure out how to stop a landslide Changes.
As hot and threatening as that sounds.
I'm not going anywhere.
We're tied for the bottom.
With fucking invisigal.
Not for long.
Oh.
Okay, they're forcing me.
I sent out the same damn couple earlier.
Here, again.
Sonar pushed me in the pool during the water aerobics class.
Why are you going to an aerobics class on the same- Don't
promise a man, Boots.
They refuse to let me leave.
Describe your diarrhea.
Oh, they...
Oh, okay.
There was a class and he pushed her in.
And now they're like, Hey, we won't let you go home.
What happened?
What is...
She's fine.
What is going on?
Walked into my sword with her face a little bit.
And now he...
I don't believe in punching women.
What's happening?
Yeah, try it.
Just play the loud sound of deaf and sonar.
Plug your ears?
I don't know.
Just...
Can he even do that?
His ears are so big.
Uh-oh.
Injured.
This is so bad.
Did you at least do the job?
Changes, but I...
Maybe if you weren't so busy fucking around with each other.
My gotcha rate is like in the toilet right now.
The mascot Inquisition.
I cannot outrun them forever.
Catch up and protect.
Okay.
We're gonna visit gal and golem.
Oh, wait.
What's it going to be this time?
Wait, what was it?
And then talking?
Wait, who's the catch up part?
Or...
Why is it...
Dispatch.
You're gonna be online tonight?
What's going on?
Woo!
Hey, Robert.
I'm pretty sure I've got the scammer on the line.
Okay, I got you.
Synergy.
Oh, whoops.
We got this.
All right, let's see where this asshole is.
Yeah, there's so much happening all at once.
Whoa, oh, match the frequency.
Warmer.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I'm not very good at this, I think.
Nearly there.
Ah, hi!
Wait, what happened?
I'll match it again.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Got him.
Oh, so there was two.
Scammer hacked, baby.
Easy peasy.
Can we get some help over here?
Hour.
I love minor inconvenience being just like a...
There's like the people that call 911 when they're like, I'm
in...
I have a complaint to the manager.
Reroute the traffic and keep it flowing.
Lift their spirits and grab their attention.
Okay, so we definitely need Prism.
but okay okay what is reroute what would you do to reroute
something
uh my cheeseburger isn't cheese enough i was like is it
smarts or is it combat because you're like picking up the
cars smarts maybe everybody is okay let's try coop graceful
but deadly and then this one a cargo aboard is minutes away
from colliding with the stopped freight at the station okay
halt the train before it crashes rescue the precious cargo
aboard i think we could send these to heading there yeah
okay all right so far uh oh when they're injured i forget
that they're like okay like they're still available
Imagine we lost that 96%.
Yippee!
Okay, good job, team.
Oh, it...
Oh, nice, okay.
I'm confused.
I thought that would be more difficult.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
They're turning around.
They're...
Everybody's coming around.
Wow.
You're on fire today.
Doki lost some 85% stuff.
No way.
I'm just warming up.
After a success, Flambe gains one combat, one mobility.
The effect stack.
Stack for the whole workday or forever?
Oh, wait.
All boosts reset after a failure.
Okay.
Let's see.
What are we going to give you?
Hmm.
Oh, for the workday.
Okay, okay.
Stacks for the work.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Doki lost a 92% and lost like five other 80% goals of the
same ship.
Sounds like a skill issue.
I think Punch-Up needs to be stronger.
I think he needs to be stronger.
Everybody rest.
Burglars spotted.
Headed towards the alley on the green.
Oh.
I'll handle this.
I can't, I can't.
She has to go do it.
Stay out of my way.
Fuck off.
What are you doing in Visigau?
Why is there a cat mascot?
It's like you said.
The way to win this leaderboard game is to not lose, right?
Yeah, that's not what I said.
I'm pretty sure that's what you said.
Is she sabotaging her?
Oh, man.
Oh, he's sad.
Oh, it's this guy again.
This well and everybody sabotages?
I don't know, I'm not doing that well, I think.
The proof that just ran by was light and struck, this is now
the second time.
No shit?
That's crazy.
I thought you weren't trying to get cut!
I think you deserve this.
She's got the buster sword and everything.
I'd normally say cut it but then the way things are going I
cut the whole damn team yeah reset Robbie all Z team back to
base and in the conference room in 20 minutes come on Z team
come on oh lack of team synergy what rude
Screaming that guy's ear.
I would go up behind him and I'd yell.
Anyone else think this is a waste of time?
Yeah, I know.
Whoa.
I had a thousand better things to do.
There is so many more people than you want.
I was about to hit the gym to give Teresa the same support
if it worked out.
All right, team.
Can everybody take a seat so we can get started?
Okay, team.
Hey, can I get your attention, please?
I would like to get started.
You think great, however?
Oh, thank you.
Oh, I forgot about Gala.
Oh, it looks like this motherfucker's got the power to fly.
Kick him out.
We need the respect.
Hey, you.
Get out of here.
Yeah, you.
Fucking Barney Rubble, fuck off.
You can ask one of your teammates to fill you in later.
Golly, boy.
Then I won't just kick you out of this room.
I'll kick you out of the whole Phoenix program.
You can go back to whatever life was so lame that you
thought coming here was an improvement.
Or you can step outside and think about...
what you want from all of this why you're here yeah
something everyone in this room should be thinking about
yeah he says i'm mud he would say i'm mad but he's literally
mud what's golem sitting outside for he's in timeout time
out everybody time out i love the minus two and plus two
right I know he's not getting kicked.
Let's go, come on, fucking wasting my time.
Okay, as you know, by the end of today, one of you will be
cut from the Z team.
This is bullshit.
Yeah, you said that already.
Call me from a job I didn't want in the first place.
Then why are you here?
His name is Mood.
You wouldn't have to throw no one out.
Hey, Nikki Mirage, I'm standing right here.
You can talk to me.
I wasn't talking to you, bitch.
Which weak-ass superhero team did you come from?
Fucking Geek Squad?
Doesn't matter where I'm from, Cardi C.
what matters is i'm here to figure out who stays and who
goes yeah chill out lady ha ha this game is gonna be so
dated in a couple years you hipster motherfucker over here
looking like mumford it's gonna be so bad that was funny you
can see we're just busting balls keep talking you won't have
your tiny ember balls left to bust ask next time or there
won't be a next time don't write me you better night okay
they're gonna it's like 10 years they'll be like to mickey
who Who is that a reference to?
And see a bunch of villains.
Not even the super kind, just plain ass, run in the mill,
vanilla fucking villains.
Not vanilla.
But that's not what I see.
Like Cardi D-minus.
Yeah, good way, good way.
Because lucky for you, I'm not most people.
When I look around this room, what I see is...
Potential.
Oh my god, just like Gus.
Both are in the end.
Unfortunately for you, it's a curse.
Because there isn't a thing in the universe that goes more
ways it then potential and despite how common it is no one
seems to forget it's what they whisper when you leave the
room oh so and so had so much potential it follows you
forever i'm here to help you lift the curse of potential
yeah by getting you to fucking do something with it oh a
superhero you're all part of the phoenix program any of you
know what a phoenix is oh um city in arizona Nah, Florida's
the dick.
Then Louisiana's gotta be the ball sack.
Just, you know, position.
The Phoenix...
Sorry.
According to legend, is a beautiful bird of prey that was so
tired of its immortality it tricked the sun god into
dropping a spark on its nest to set it ablaze.
Burning it to shit.
But instead of dying, the Phoenix emerged from ash.
You are all Phoenixes!
All of you in this room are Phoenixes, and it's obvious what
that...
means but for you dumb ones i'll spell it out the phoenix
symbolizes oh my gosh this is hololive miss right here you
can't remember your favorite you were meant to be a member
this is also a lame ass band my lame ass roommate listens to
you're late i like that band you would what are you talking
about i was here the whole time i turned invisible genius
remember i forgot she was i forgot about her great then you
know we're cutting someone and you, Miss Hot Topics Sale,
are at the bottom of the leaderboards.
Have a better second shift.
Ooh.
What for a coup?
We all know you'll just be working the roulette wheel.
That's a croupier, you idiot.
That's a croupier.
You said Gura outside!
Why is she the mud man?
Yeah, this is our idol.
group you guys great speech back there robert thanks oh
thank you all right everyone you heard the man get out there
and do some stellar dispatch yeah you got this okay all
right oh everybody first job my client requires protection
while he does some shopping oh i remember this man and he's
right to be paranoid secret police hired me three years ago
to kill him you're all diamond dot wait phoenix way oh my
gosh robert is big boss Protect the subscriber from agents
of international dictators while he shops Be prepared to
fend off any incoming attacks Alright, we need someone
tough, tough, tough, baby Um
You know what, golem We'll send in golem Wait, no?
Is he mad at me?
Is he mad?
No He wouldn't be mad at me Yeah He's a...
Google Maps is being weird, but I'll be there.
Oh my god, he's angry at me!
I just sent him the time out.
He's like, I don't want to do my job.
I'm Engy.
Some bitch just cut me in line at the Utopia concert.
I've been here for 12 fucking hours.
Cool.
Peaceful.
Oh.
You basic bet.
We're all diamonds.
I won't scatter your soul to the heart this year.
to a girl who knows four chords and can't write a song to
save her life.
Say what you want.
It's catchy.
Unbelievable.
I think we should send out who's a good smooth talker
besides Prism.
Uh...
No, Robert is little, boys.
Yeah, because he's so little.
Jeannie, welcome to Vembooship.
Thank you.
He didn't hear your speech from outside.
Aw.
He's feeling unmotivated.
we'll send it we'll send on the move yeah we'll send him we
could also
we could send we'll send them both ready as ever they got
this okay how to go how to go mr flame man oh yeah you know
what that that'll do that'll do don't get that That'll do.
On fuego.
Yo, Mal, what kind of music you got in your heavy rotation
right now?
You know, honestly, it's a little skull.
But I had like a really big technology face recently too.
The line cutter actually pulled out a knife!
Actually, several knives!
Do you like the sensation of your ears bleeding?
Oh, you know what?
Oh.
I'm good.
All right.
All for me.
Um, you know what?
Well, if she wants a fight, yeah.
I think our, I think our, we're pretty good.
Our attack, yeah.
Oh, I think I'm starting to understand it.
So if my stat is here, but...
Okay, okay, I get it, I get it.
I'm understanding the game.
Oh, what's happening here?
I think there's some kind of cult recruiting outside my
store.
They're creeping everyone out.
Wow!
Identify the loiterers' recruitment goals and tell them to
disperse.
Identify and speak.
Okay.
This street preacher needs to work on a sandwich.
Everybody's getting along, you guys.
Everybody's getting along.
Oh, we also need to do this.
Let's see.
I feel like I need more charisma on people.
Everybody's lacking in speech ability.
Oh my goodness.
You guys can't talk yourselves out of anything.
We're a team.
Uh-oh.
The matching jumpsuit weirdos are definitely a cult that's
recruiting what's the best approach just how wait we could
have we could have become the the God of their cold destroy
their literature free their minds I'm so curious what that
means oh
oh yes good they've been shooed We freed them.
Half man, half bat, all freak.
All freak.
Half man, half bat.
And so charisma when he is a bat would go into vigor, right?
We'll do charisma then.
So right now he's a mega bat, so he's like, he looks like
this.
Okay, okay.
Half man.
There's a bunch of men in the base.
of the Gigaburger for some kind of fight club.
I don't know how they got here, but they need to go.
There's been fighting tourneys ever since the first chimp
made a fist.
You're crazy if you think you can shut this down.
Well, Punch Up, it could be your honor.
Shut down the underground fight ring in the basement of
Gigab...
Oh, wait, hold on.
Before we do that, let's upgrade somebody else.
Oh, Prism.
Let's...
Hmm.
How do I want to?
More charisma.
Let's see.
Okay, shut it down.
Anticipate resistance.
Resistance, would that mean, like, physical or they want to
chat with us?
You know?
On my way.
We can do both.
Okay.
We can send...
On my way.
It's a fight club.
Okay, so they want to fight.
Look at this.
We can't be any stronger.
Mark my words.
We ain't stopping nothing.
So you might as well send me in.
Yeah, that's what I did.
My client requires protection at lunch with the governor of
California.
Woody's still alive.
Are you going soft on his coop?
Please.
They couldn't pay.
So I canceled the job.
No cash no kill so far full-on brawl exactly as long as the
checks clear I will kill or protect as they see fit Let's
see I thought they didn't let us kill people around here as
they see That
We'll do coop and Whoa, whoa We knew me Fucking rocks knew
me uh yeah no you're actually you're rocks and mud buddy
you've always been rocks actually you've never stopped being
rocks
the turn he is down everyone
um let's put okay you're are you're pretty well rounded
right now let's do some more into intelligence, I think.
Word on the street is the tourney just relocated.
We massively lunch enjoyed.
That was a...
Wait, what are you doing?
Where are you going?
Koopay?
I learned from my sources that the next tournament will be
held at the refinery in one hour.
Oh, also.
Oh, oh, oh.
She's looking for a fight club, baby.
Let's, um...
I'll put a little more charisma in you.
Because you need some help.
Speaking, I think.
For you, we'll do...
Also, charisma in you.
Everybody's a smooth talker on my team.
Fight in the tournament!
shut down the tournament.
Bye.
Wait.
Come on, Robert.
Send me in to compete.
I'll win so hard.
We'll bankrupt every bookie in torrents.
Try not to get killed?
All right.
Hero training.
Punch up.
You will be magnificent.
Let's learn to fly.
Your flight-capable heroes need a flight lesson.
Whoa.
I want to get this guy out of my team, so we'll send in the
bat.
Cool.
Maybe this whole leaderboard thing goes away.
Maybe flamb.
Why?
I don't like him, though.
I don't want him in my sand.
Desperate fucks.
It's my game, guys.
Uh oh.
Hey, Bobby, you think you could send someone?
I need a corner man or woman.
Maybe coupe?
Coupe?
Okay.
You can go.
25.
Uh, what?
Who's gonna tell her?
Don't tell me anything.
I don't want any spoilers.
Also, you guys telling me that is like...
Now you're making me feel like I made the wrong choice.
You guys made me feel like I made the wrong choice.
My client requires protection.
Okay.
A lot of protection stuff.
Going in.
Look at that.
That's craziness.
Guess what?
Chicken butt.
Yo, go along.
I fuck with potpourri, so are, bro.
Potpourri?
Dang.
Okay, okay, I see you.
How'd it go?
I was not, bro.
Strong bag.
It transformed.
If transform sonar flies to call locations, greatly reducing
travel.
Nice.
Yay.
Okay.
And if SDN disagrees with me, they're more than welcome to
come on.
Oh, we got the Bowen Zone again.
Get on the air with the Bowen Zone for a friendly debate.
Okay.
Friendly.
Robert is mecha man.
But no one's supposed to know his identity!
He wears... Oh, he doesn't even wear glasses, actually.
Videos are for music.
Fuck that guy.
Uh-oh, everybody's busy right now.
Guys?
Uh-oh.
Oh, Flamb.
About your position at the top with a leaderboard.
I took a little peek at your file.
Apparently you've contained more fires than anyone else.
You guys can't just be doxing people like that.
It's really disrespectful.
Can you guys shut up so I can read this?
We have eyes on the assassin.
Looks like red ring.
What is red ring?
Um, challenge him.
Kick his butt.
I think we could do it.
Oh yeah.
Assassin taken down.
Client protected.
Everybody?
Save.
Dinner served.
Watch me burn.
Who's going to...
Who's graduating?
Hold the fuck up.
Punch.
Red Ring is the gang shroud lead.
Oh, okay, thank you.
Oh, my God.
That was...
Look at that!
Oh, wait.
They're so cute.
Special technique.
Real classy stuff.
They're so cute.
Maybe if you ask nice, I'll tell you about it.
If there's someone who needs extra hero training, I've got
free time right now.
I'll set it around.
Um...
One second.
Let's use our points.
Oh...
He's kind of dumb, so we'll make him a little smarter.
Actually, no.
We'll give you more charisma.
And then who else?
Oh, punch up.
Punch up!
Keep on!
Punching up, baby.
Client protected.
Hotel Travago.
Hero training, huh?
Well...
I have, you know...
I've got a lot of people that are like resting and all,
so...
You know, we just...
My tail's wagging, I swear.
Cute!
Uh-oh!
Lightning struck spotted.
Urgent care on Boone Street.
Apprehend lightning struck.
Go quickly before he gets away.
Don't underestimate him.
Oh!
I already tangled with this dickwad once.
Send someone else.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I can't only send one guy though.
Everybody's resting.
I could pull somebody out of resting.
I do have that.
I am at the Torrance Bank and there's these guys with masks
and guns.
Approach swiftly.
Send someone else.
I'm physical!
I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna literally...
I'm gonna, I'm gonna...
Yeah, I need the coffee.
Wait, okay.
Take a hero out of resting.
They're all really close though.
Hold on.
Okay, wait, F.
Now I can do it for, like, Prism or Malevolo.
Ah, beautiful.
Okay, now we have more people.
Okay, fast.
We need fast.
Let's see.
I think you missed a job.
You guys, it's okay.
I think that's gonna happen.
Holy moly.
When did he get so strong?
When did his...
When did his stats become like this?
It's his ability.
Oh, that's right.
Every time he...
Uh...
Right.
Sweet ass.
Honestly, I'm like, do we need anybody else?
Passive buffs.
Watch me whip this amateur's ass.
Alright, let's put Golem in.
him feel better his last job wait maybe he's good maybe i
don't wanna once per shift all of golem stats can be reset
within the hero database allowing for redistribution oh
interesting i like how he is right now though oh whoops my
bad get me out of here oh wait oh i have to unlock that or
golem expands to fill each empty slot increasingly
increasingly his stats by 25% per slot.
Up to 200% when beneficial.
Oh.
I think that one's better.
Yeah, I missed this one.
Pupsy pupsy.
But honestly, I had nobody to send.
I had to get this one.
I clicked it and then it immediately expired on this one.
So it is what it is.
Nana!
Thank you so much for the thing gifted.
Thank you.
Yeah!
Holy cow!
I'm not fucking around, all right?
Oh my god, that was close.
Pretty breathtaking work back there.
Not too shabby.
Hey, what are you doing?
It's not too shabby at all.
Why'd she run away?
It's like we're working.
What's the word?
As a team.
Uh-huh.
Baby, that's got a name.
It's teamwork.
Yeah!
That's like a sex thing.
What type of sex thing would that be?
It's not really safe for work, you know?
Yeah.
I'll text it to you.
One sec.
Oh, damn, boy.
That's some fucking teamwork.
All right.
Continue.
I don't want to hear anymore.
Please keep going.
Where are you going?
Hello?
I air tagged her.
It's fine.
TMI to me.
There you go.
One more strike against me.
You got to get rid of somebody, right?
for you why are they making her like the main character
you're not making it easy for me you're making it easy for
you you don't get it some people are born to be heroes I'm
not one of them I tried just wasn't meant to be you have
like the easiest superpower to be a superhero though she
kind of is oh flying through the sky nothing to hide what's
your point I have fucking villain powers I can turn
invisible and skulk in the shadows my powers let me steal
shit and watch famous people fuck being a villain is my fate
it's in the fucking stars how would you in the same way that
screw the stars was always meant to be a hero words pretend
phantom okay I don't know if you don't know why are you
still talking they're not even real okay any message you're
seeing the stars aren't real is that what you just said
robert roberton if you're getting any messages it's useless
because it was for some that died a long time ago you've
already been a hero stars they're not real you have no idea
what i'm dealing with space get out of here social construct
at least you were born with powers i don't have so according
to your dumbass theory i should be an accountant you aren't
far off depression none of these things got me from being a
hero before and they won't keep me from being a hero again
yeah we're glory in progress at the jewelry store oh my god
you want to talk this guy again that lightning struck fuck
that's been on a spree is two blocks from your location
maybe it's third times the charm let's go baby I'm out you
really want to let this idiot get one over on you a third
time this could make a difference yeah this guy and it could
make a difference he's still a roll of pennies out of the
cash register of grannies i don't think he's moving the
needle oh he's about to steal a quarter of a million dollars
of jewelry oh shit respect respect move the needle or are
you just gonna sit there and subject kids to secondhand
smoke oh no you'll have asthma also what are you doing girl
don't do it don't fucking get that kid a cigarette Oh!
My god!
Oh!
He was just gonna let you finish him.
Are you...
You ain't worried about a hero crashing the party?
I think you could have just smashed that.
Load that up.
Oh!
Where's your boy?
Shit.
Yeah.
Like being invisible is like so awesome.
I would do totally legal operations that help the community
but also I'm a ghost so it's kind of the same got him we
know is that your five o'clock I want to donut me too I I'm
I'm flying blind here I can't see Uh-oh.
Great.
Give me a second to tap into this.
Okay, I'm hacking.
I'm ready.
Give me a second.
Or two.
Not even.
One.
All right.
A little more tricky.
Oh.
Oh my god.
What is that?
Oh, it's a thing that eats you.
I was curious about going to it.
Okay.
I need to run from it.
What?
What is it?
Antivirus.
I went straight to him.
It looked so...
It looked magical.
Like, it's so mysterious.
Where the hell is he?
Actual moth to a flame moment.
It's fine.
It wasn't time.
Let me try to get another one online.
I have to do this again?
Okay.
We got this.
everybody
you can't touch me i'm too good of a hacker
he's at your seven that wasn't so hard was it he's heading
your way you could have just looked up walking around.
I think you could hear him though.
Sprinkler time!
Master.
What am I doing?
Maybe we should communicate.
There we go.
Oh, oh I have to loop him.
You fuck you, fuck you, fuck you.
Yeah!
Yeah, screw you!
Oh my god.
Yeah, Robert, what's the plan?
Maybe we should, like, tell her what it is.
On the count of three, I'm going to turn on the main
overhead lights, which should temporarily blind him.
That was close.
One.
Three.
Yeah!
Oh.
Oh, that's one strong rope.
Holy cow.
The strongest set of pearls a lady could ask for.
I'm no hero.
Fuck, no, let me try that again.
Yeah, you see me?
Wait, uh, what about?
Lights out, Thunder Cook.
Oh.
That's the one.
No, I don't think so.
You said it first.
Right, because lightning thunder struck Cook, look so close.
Oh, it's fine.
Hey, Bengal boy.
Bitch, boy, yeah.
Aw,
everybody's clapped.
Everybody clapped.
Why are these assholes not being assholes?
Isn't this what you were going for?
Yeah, but I didn't think it would work.
I don't get it.
So...
This one keeps the comm line one-on-one.
This one connects to the whole team.
And this one goes out to the entire branch.
Good job.
Yeah, you got off light.
One dispatcher broadcast the details of his botched
circumcision.
HR nightmare.
Did you mean all that?
You really think she has a shot?
All that stuff about fate sounded good, but...
Everyone has a shot.
I don't know if you were just saying...
I said I was going to be the asshole guy.
but I'm totally not being it all.
Everyone has a shot.
I totally went against my plan.
I feel like that's like a second playthrough kind of thing,
though, no.
It's a steep learning curve.
It's fun.
Ah, maybe I'm too, I don't know.
I'm too many feelings.
This mission was textbook.
Genuinely, dude, I'm really happy for you.
Aw.
Sonar and Coop.
Coop!
That's not, no.
Invisigal's still at the bottom of the board.
Oh, the one in the bullpen?
That thing updates every hour.
Invisigal moved up.
Oh.
Catching lightning struck really gave her a huge boost.
Bangal boy.
Wait, but I just taught him how to fly.
The donut shop escape.
Slipping past Malevila.
Now the jewelry store.
Really bumped up the wanted levels.
And I made him.
It's like missing the free throw on purpose to get the put
back.
Yeah, exactly.
I don't watch football, but I get it.
I think you guys read the subtitles.
I can't read them because my mouse is frozen.
can't scroll up even if she was on the bottom i'm not sure
i'd have let you cut her then is a good thing she's not yeah
so these two are now tied for last place who do we cut sonar
or coop i can't cut coop she's too good i support it all the
way nice by sonar sonar it is it was so fast it's a stress
beacon before you even left the building today so i'm not
sure it's gonna work Wait, what?
You thought he was gonna see boobs and got tricked.
Yeah, he's done that a couple times now.
Not enough detail in one sentence.
He's done that a couple times.
I'll get started on the paperwork.
I'll let him know.
It's kind of stupid.
Me too cute.
Hey, uh, Robert.
Great work today.
Thank you.
My coop is way too good!
So, I'm sure you know why you're here.
No, not at all, man.
clue what's up what's going on robbie you uh well i'm
cutting you did you train him to fly i didn't know it was
gonna get cut so she she should be getting cut she's on the
bottom not anymore actually her last dispatch put her above
you sonar will remember that
oh security good timing this is over it actually is sorry it
didn't work out back robert why is this what did you do uh
no you uh you must have just locked it sorry for firing so
hard is going to break long wait why did it censor the
middle finger unless his middle finger is shaped like a
coupe will remember that right coupe you'll remember that i
didn't fire you
his tie will remember it no way a momento of the people you
accessorizing we fire did he try to choke you with that or
something no he just left it you're lucky he just stopped at
the time hey check it out i've been doing some accessorizing
myself yeah what we got here oh whoa
cute i wonder when the donut store Closes.
Leaf bird.
Oh.
Oh!
Is she taking a picture of it?
Wait, that's so cute.
Oh!
Oh, she's just Sundere, everybody.
I think I understand why people...
Okay, I think she was the character that people don't like,
right?
I thought it was the blonde girl, but now I understand.
Well, no one fucking asks you, old man.
Sundere to normies, people hate Sundere girls.
Like, normies, rather, normies hate Sundere girls.
It's kind of insane.
But, yeah.
You'll see why they hate her?
Uh, well, you know, whatever.
But it's true, though.
People don't.
You 37% of people cut sonar.
Not a lot of people, huh?
Everybody wanted voice critical on their team, I guess.
I guess.
But it's true.
I'm not just talking about in this scenario, though.
Wow, Derek Taco!
Oh my gosh!
It's been a while.
Thank you so much for the Tony gift, and thank you!
Um, I see so many comments sometimes on, like, um, on like,
I don't even know what the videos are like, but they'll be
like, oh yeah, Taiga from Toradora, she sucks.
I can't stand her.
She's so annoying.
Because she's Sundere!
I don't know, like, why?
What is this Tundere, like...
Like...
Just...
What is this hatred?
Where is this hatred coming from?
They like hate the trope.
It's kind of crazy.
And Taiga!
Taiga of all people.
Makes me angry.
I know.
I'm like, what's happening?
What's happening with like this strange...
dislike of Tundere?
Hmm.
You and 24% of players kicked out Gollum.
Kicked Gollum out of the conference room.
Sorry, Gollum.
Look how sad he looks.
He needed the timeout.
Oh, I see it.
Aaron Paul.
Young Gravy.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You and 99% of players helped Invisa Gallagher against
Lightning Struck.
Wait, you could not help?
There's an option to not help?
How do you not help?
I was just following the story.
I guess if you like...
Timuro!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
If you fail the hack...
Oh, okay.
1%.
The 1% are bad at gaming.
They actually really like Taiga.
They're just being tuned to now.
You and 64% of players said all of you are Phoenixes.
You and 32% said F the stars.
Out of the five times a hero was sabotaged, you helped them
escape with no injuries four times.
Dang!
I think that was pretty good, no.
You and 9% of players sent Punch-Up and Coup to compete as
a killer.
Why did nobody send them, huh?
Why?
You and 88% of players successfully protected Victor from
his enemies.
Okay.
Your most sent hero was Malibula.
30% of players in today's shift.
Wait.
Huh?
So I did poorly.
Yeah, I did poorly.
That's understandable.
People laughing at big chungus on the leaderboards are
missing names like Thunder Size and French Press.
A French Press is cute.
That's like a coffee, right?
Activated a hero's powers 27 times.
Oh, wait, wait, no, no, no episode.
I think we'll call it there, everybody.
Episode four.
We went through three episodes, so yuppie, yuppie, yuppie,
yuppie.
Yuppie, yuppie, yuppie.
Wait, when does the donut place close?
One second, though.
Let's see.
Donut.
Oh, there's a there's one that's 24 hours, but it's far
away.
Oh,
no donut denies.
Dang it.
Oh, I need to I need to go closer to the 24 hour donut
players.
How far is it?
Opening up maps.
That's far.
Well, guys, I'm going to go.
go actually i need to take out my contacts these glasses you
see that i'm wearing here they're fake wait if i zoom in
will they become bigger yeah they're fakes they're fakes i'm
a fraud i'm a hack i'm a hack gasp i know i know i fooled
you all that was my super villain tactic I'm no hero I'm the
leader of the baddies I'm the super villain I tricked you I
a twist villain Disney twist villain I led you into false
security and then I deceived you and now you'll never
actually what was the point well
You...
You will always question your surroundings.
Hi, Sabine.
Thank you, welcome back.
Play this like a damn fiddle.
She's so evil.
Yes, I am.
You will always wonder if anybody's glasses are real.
Oh.
Or cake.
Wow!
Pushes up glasses.
Big.
For me to see you with.
Anyone else think this super villain's kind of cute?
No, no, you thought I was cute with the big glasses.
But it's actually... Wait, what if they were never big
glasses?
Oh my gosh, I look like a scholar.
Yes.
Why?
If you're wondering about the answers.
Physics.
Nerd alert.
No, no, no.
No.
They're normal size.
I'm not a nerd.
That's my weakness.
No.
You can't call me a nerd.
Quick, shivering, yokey, yokey, I won't be so cute now.
Did you just say node?
Don't call me a nerd.
It's my...
Oh, it's, it's, oh, oh, it's my weakness, my, my weak, I'm,
I'm shriveling up just like the wicked witch of the West.
Oh, oh, I'm becoming so small, I'm becoming so small.
Oh, oh, I'm shriveling to be the right.
I'm just a bean.
You defeated me.
You can squash me like a bug.
I'll lay on the ground and make it easier for you guys.
There you go.
Squash me.
Squash me like a bug.
I'm waiting.
I'm waiting for you to squash me like a bug.
No!
I'll
be back.
You ain't seen the last of me.
Mega mind.
Mega...
Masterful!
Mito!
Thank you.
No, I'm supposed to be here.